hi everyone I'm six and I'm happy to be
sharing this walkthrough with you I
learned whether of myself through free
coke app three years ago and back then I
actually struggled a lot with getting my
projects online at first through cloud
nine and then Heroku and I only found
that lafay a year later I realized the
deploying and scaling is a lot easier
with the jab stack approach especially
with modern front-end frameworks like
reactant view so this is the video
series I wish I had when I started it
out I hope you enjoy so I kind of break
down the overall structure of the series
into nine parts don't worry they're not
all equally long but we're gonna start
with the main ones first the ones that
you really need to know so we'll talk
about notify edge and how nullify is
actually a CDN first hosting solution
and that's why it's fast and secure and
how we can upload and deploy without
using any of the other functionality or
nullify just deploying straight to see
the end next we'll look into net Liffe I
build and how nullify hooks up to your
git repos and continuously deploys from
them so you have version control for
your sites but also it helps you
generate your sites from static site
generators for maximum performance we
all understand the build process
especially how to debug it as well as to
manage the build environment with
environment variables as well as injects
your tokens and secrets at build time
then we'll talk about nullified dev
which helps you develop locally so you
don't even have to deploy this is
entirely within your local machine and
the and the idea is to make it a lot
easier to test serve less functions
together with your local dev environment
with hot reloading as well as anything
else that you might need to simulate
your real production environment then
we'll take a look at nullify forms and
this covers the use case where you think
you may need a server but actually you
just want to have some basic form
submission capability like a comment
system people leaving a contact form or
even file uploads and then you want to
do some basic automation with that with
zapier or a service function or other
sort of web hooks and we'll show you how
to do that in simple HTML as well as
single page apps and static site
generators then we're going to take a
look at nullify identity which helps you
add authentication and authorization to
your site and this can be very useful
for apps and e-commerce
and in particular you can use dropping
widget so you don't have to code up the
UI or you can use something lower level
that actually gives you the core
functionality and you can code your UI
on top of it we'll also talk about
authenticated functions and how nullify
identity and service functions works
work really well together as well as
other things that you might want to do
some of the people that you're working
with might actually be non-technical
users and you might want to edit content
without going straight into source code
and that's why Neto Phi has a very
wonderful open source project called
notify CMS and we'll talk about how to
set it up as well as what it does so you
can evaluate for yourself if you want to
use it or use any of the other header
CMS's out there we're then gonna talk
about nullify add-ons which are all the
other functionality of nullified that
doesn't really fit in the other buckets
above but are still very useful and you
might want to use them on certain
occasions and in particular I want to
shout out nullifying analytics which are
unblockable server-side analytics that
would be very useful for your site as
well as the add-on marketplace when Elif
is starting to have add-on partners that
include fauna DB which helps you add a
database to your Jeff Zacks site lastly
we're going to talk about the net with I
API where you can make your own elephant
client for example if the CLI and the UI
of nullify aren't exactly fitting what
you need notifies platform is entirely
documented and you can go make your own
client on top of it and a lot of users
have and finally we'll end with pointers
for learning more about nullify and gem
stack and where you can get help if you
run into trouble so hopefully that's a
good overview of what we're going to be
doing today and let's start diving it
there are few ways to deploy to nullify
now nullify drop is not the most
important way but I find it useful to
explain this first because it helps
explain the history of nullify as well
as the fundamental concept of jam stack
so nettle if I started life as a company
called bit balloon and bit balloon was a
simple service where you could drag and
drop like a folder on your desktop drag
it onto a bit pollutants web UI and have
it be deployed immediately on to a CDN
and to this day that is done if I drop
and so that is the fundamental concept
of net low fee that everything that you
deploy to nullify is static assets and
nullify it takes care of deploying it on
a CDN so all the points of presence
around the world so that your users get
them as quickly as humanly possible now
bit balloon eventually became net LeFay
and then we dropped the bit blew an
angle so if you go to the URL bar and
you type in bit balloon comm you simply
get redirected to app down elephant comm
slash drop here you can do a simple drag
and drop of your built site not the
source code the built sign and you can
scroll around to look at the features
we're gonna cover all of this in the
rest of this video if you don't have a
sample site not look for actually if it
gives one to you so just let see the
downloaded demo site button that
downloads a zip file and you can
literally just drag and drop a zip file
on to that drag field and you see how
quickly it deploys there's no editing
there it just deploys live to a live URL
and you can scroll around I mean I
really don't think there is a faster
solution to getting something online
you'd literally drag and drop it and the
whole thing just deploys for you on a
CDN so that's the fastest solution now
I'm also gonna try to edit this site I'm
gonna unzip that zip file into a folder
and then you can look around you can see
all the assets like a typical site I'm
gonna choose my favorite editor I use vs
code it doesn't really matter what you
use but here in vs code I can just drop
drag and drop the file from my file
explorer to vs code and now I have that
project open and now I can surf around
and look and look at the index.html for
example and this is a standard HTML site
nothing no frameworks nothing and I'm
just gonna edit
the text to see how it shows up and
instantly deploys changes so now I'm
saving it and and so I've edited that
site and now I can actually choose to
compress that site and zip it up again
to a zip file and now I can go back to
that deploy page and if I want to update
that site I can just go down to the
deploy section and drag and drop just
like I did to initiate that site so I
just drag and drop it and now it's
uploading and now it's published and
when I click on it and I hit to refresh
that site it's uploaded with the new
changes so that's an elephant drop you
can always access the previous deploy
with a with a unique URL so if you click
down in here you can access the previous
deploy
you can even roll it back so if you want
you can just say publish deploy and now
when i refresh this original URL i
refresh it it goes back to the original
version because every single deploy is
immutable so you can always roll back
something if you need to and we don't
expect you to drag and drop every time
so the next method I'm gonna cover is
using the notify CLI this is a pretty
big topic that actually deserves a
separate video but here we're only going
to use another five satellite to deploy
so I'm gonna go back to the folder that
I had which which I'm editing the file
in and I can pull up the terminal in
Thea's code I already have the nullify
CLI installed but if you need to you can
run NPM install global notify - CLI and
that will install for you I'm running an
l5 version of 2.12 you can run nullify
status to check if you're logged in I am
and you can run login no if I log in if
you're not now I'm gonna edit my HTML
again to indicate that I'm using the no
I'm deploying from the know if I see a
lot I'm just gonna say in Elif I see a
lie
rulz
so we'll see that if we should see that
if we deployed
so down in here I'm gonna write metal I
deploy for brevity because this is a lot
to type you can actually use NTL and
network
and we'll see what we get so the first
thing it tells me is that this folder is
an entry site
I don't I have an existing site that I
want to link to but we'll avoid that for
now and just create a new site and we'll
do the linking later so we're creating
configuring your site they'll ask you to
pick your team's or it's likely that
you'll you just have one or two teams so
just pick their appropriate team and
then you can pick something like another
five demo site
now it's asking you for the deploy path
in most cases you can just go with
whatever suggested but will talk to me
will tell you how to how to configure
this later
and so now it's uploaded all of these
pieces of information and actually
showed you what it's done as well as
given you a URL where you can actually
go check it out
so here because I've only I've only
chosen notify deploy by default it
deploys to a draft URL so you can see
what it looks like in production
before you actually push it to a master
if you're happy with this and you
actually want to push it to master just
run nullified deployed - - product
and that's that does exactly the same
thing as now if I deploy but it pushes
it directly the Center for draft URL it
pushes it directly
so here we have a live Europe so if we
click this and we should be able to see
the CLI roles on the mains on the main
URL instead of the the draft Europe
again remember that each of these
deployments is immutable so you can roll
back to it at any time or give give this
and say a link to a friend's or
colleague for reviewing whatever content
or code changes you now notice that it
keeps prompting me for a deploy path if
you want to actually just hard code that
there are a few different ways to do it
but the way that I will recommend is to
create an elephant tamil file so I'm
gonna exit out of this process and I'm
gonna create a new file so this is an
example nullify combo that I have just
saved on my copy of my clipboard manager
well good we're gonna comment this out
for now and we're just gonna focus on
the published directory so the published
directory is the directory that we want
to zip up and send out to the CDN
nullify down in here we usually use a
dist folder but here I'm just deploying
the root folder so we can just say dot
run nullify deploy prod and I
and no longer being and and I'm no
longer being asked about where my
publish deploy path is
[Music]
of course I can move all of the assets
into a published folder so something
like
list and I can move all of the assets
here so now it looks a lot cleaner and I
can build from a source code director so
then I would have to change my publish
to a tree accordingly to the dist folder
so I only publish anything inside of
this and anything outside of this does
not get and I can now identify we
actually really encourage using version
control and we call it get centric
workflow so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to initiate get so get in it
now you notice one new folder that was
created then I haven't explained yet is
the dot nullify folder it really is just
a simple little JSON file that stores
where you've linked what site you've
linked the project to so for example if
over here
I run nullify status you can actually
see not just my login information but
which site this particular folder this
particular project has been linked to so
it says down here notify site info and
it gives me all that stuff and you can
notice the site ID is an exact match
State Jason
so obviously this dot nullify folder
it's pretty helpful for now if I see
Ally to understand what site is linked
to but it may not be so helpful for an
open-source project for example where
people downloading your repo might not
have access to the same site so checking
that in might confuse them however
actually checking that in for a team
project is probably pretty handy so that
people don't have to set up their own
sites it's really up to you but I
personally generally get ignore the
Anila 5 folder and it really depends on
the use case whether you do that so I've
gone and gonna go I'm going to edit the
content over here so we also reflect
that
we're deploying from get this time and
we'll see what happens with that so now
I can say you get at everything get
commit
become a better message than I have and
now we had not only have to set up a
remote nullify works with good lab
bitbucket and github obviously I am most
familiar with github so I'm gonna use
that but feel free to use whatever give
provider care about so notify what am i
calling it
of the site pastor and here
so I can copy that URL and just say get
remote at origin and now I have that
linked up I can actually say get
so that when i refresh over here I can
see that I
push my site up to get so surprisingly
we've gone through two of the methods
and we're actually well set up to do
continuous deployment notify and I'm
gonna show you what that looks like
right now so if we go to
that was my home page
these are all the sites that I have
currently but you can also click a new
site from get you can choose to set up
continuous deployment from one of these
providers obviously I choose
and I can select that repo that I just
so you'll notice over here that it reads
the nullifier tamil file that we've made
and it's also created some other options
that you might want to look into as well
when we'll talk about the build command
when we to get to the build site so
we're just gonna hit deploy site and it
really is that simple
so this deploy should be done pretty
quickly and once you click that site you
should be able to see nullify from get
directly as pushed from our local dirt
local development to github and from
github pulled into now let's have a look
at what continuous deployment workflow
looks like so I'm gonna go over to my
deploys view and then I'm also going to
go over to my project I'm going to say
I'm gonna make some edits as well so I'm
going to say your name was climate is
the best because it is I'm going to get
to and get push origin master
that's just an alias that I have set up
locally so that's going to deploy
straight to github and that's gonna kick
off a build in here and that's just an
underlying secret about how nullify
works is to automate this in time so now
so now that there's no build time so it
just basically deployed immediately and
and so now when I head back to the
original site goofy Austin eight I can
see it's the best over in github I can
also refresh and see my change down in
here and that's continuous deployment
that the idea that your deploys update
in lockstep with your git don't forget
that you can always roll things back if
you made a mistake or if you're not
ready to release something so for
example I can publish this this old
deploy and if I head back to the site
and refresh it goes back to the original
and get message and the next version is
still here so that's how we launch some
of our features if you want to turn off
continuous deployment for some reason
you can click stop auto publishing and
that will stop and now when I make some
more changes stop
again this is a good alias just for me
to be a little bit quicker in my actions
so now when I see this update coming in
it actually has built and deployed it
just isn't published yet
you can see this little lock icon
because I've stopped Auto publishing so
when i refresh my page haven't changed
anything in terms of the text because I
haven't published the latest update if I
want to kick it back on again it doesn't
immediately promote the latest deploy to
the published site because you may not
want that to happen so you're gonna have
to go in here and only then you'll see
the new text push ticket so a lot of the
secret around how this is done is
basically setting up internal billhooks
you can actually set up your own build
hooks down in here in the settings and
it just gives you a URL you can use to
trigger a build so let's have a look at
how that works so I can give this a name
for example demo oh and you can give it
a branch to build here I only have
master but you can imagine building
other batches and you can save it and
that gives you a build hook with which
to use so now I'm going to oh and there
is a very useful curl command so I can
actually paste at it so let's head over
to the deploy section and I'm gonna
bring up my terminal copied from the
billhook section so I'm gonna see that I
fired this off and now if I wait long
enough or I refresh I can see that a new
hook has been triggered by the demo
people use build hooks for all sorts of
things for example you can go to if this
than that and trigger builds on a tweet
for example or you can set the scheduled
job from zapier or any other cron
service to build every minute every day
of yahwah whatever suits your build
process for example one of my co-workers
fauxhawk Seraph actually built a clock
set your watch by an elephant calm this
is an a dynamically updated
javascript clock it literally builds
every minute so now if i refresh you can
actually see the time update accordingly
for the last method of deploying it's
more of a fun demo and not something
you're likely to use more than once but
it's handy to have around especially for
open source projects if you have any
nullified on Taobao configured correctly
then you can also setup a one-click
deploy to nullify button that's pretty
easy to get going
so i'm going to go to my github
directory that i've setup in the course
of this video i'm gonna copy that URL
I'll head to the deploy button Doc's on
nullify calm and then I'll just paste
that in here and that will configure
various things like the markdown snippet
HTML and elm snippet if you use out but
here I'm just gonna copy a markdown
snippet what the help me do is paste it
directly into my readme
so you can say things like that point to
nullified and down it here so I'm gonna
commit this again
you deploy to nullify and I'll push to
master
and now when i refresh I get this nice
deploy to nullify button so it's nice to
display on your Doc's especially for
open source boilerplates and projects
because what that enables people to do
people who are not you is to click that
button and get that one click deploy
experience so for example here it says
connect to github I'll give this a
different name and it's going to set up
a site and set up that continuous
deployment and for to your repo all in
the process of one click so whoever is
working on their new site can get the
benefits of this latest site from you
but then they also have a fork with
which to start work on so that's what
the deployment notify button is is just
a streamlined process it's useful for
open source boilerplate authors so now
we're done talking about ways to deploy
things on nella fine notice that we
haven't talked about build cuz that's a
different stage of the deploy cycle
where you may have to set the build
command and we'll come to that in a bit
but I wanted to spend some time talking
about what you get by default because
these are things where there's nothing
to cover because you got it by default
already but it's good to be aware of
what you get for free so the first thing
to notice is that you get HTTPS by
default so that's a more encrypted
protocol where you're not susceptible to
man-in-the-middle attack and that's just
a best practice for modern websites by
default you also get deploy previews so
I'm gonna do a little demo of that with
our demo site I'm going to create a new
branch
you say new your feature for example
and I'm going to edit that in here
awesome new feature
and I'm gonna save that feature pushed
ah and get push origin new feature and
then I'm gonna go create a PR on github
so I've been working on a branch I have
an awesome new feature I'll leave a
comment please
create a pull request
and will let us perform some checks but
you can see that automatically some
things happen that you may not
necessarily have on a normal site and so
this is a deploy preview basically
saying that even a PR which hasn't been
murdered I can actually check out
over here where it says awesome new
feature and it has and it gives me a
label of deploy preview one
and that is a preview that I can share
with my clients or my coworker sometimes
if you're using for example a static
site generator you may want to check out
if pages or redirects have change so you
can click on their details and it brings
you in to nullify where you can look at
look at what pages have changed in
particular and that should be exactly
what you expect in terms of pages once
you're happy with your preview you can
merge it in and that should also kick
off a new build on the master branch so
that's a very nice workflow from
previewing the new feature before you
merge and then merging it in once you're
happy and having your customers here if
there are default to know about is that
nullify is a CDN by default so all of
your deploys are distributed to the
nearest points of presence this isn't
documented everywhere because the list
keeps changing but as of as of the time
of this recording the regular free tier
gets a few locations Frankfurt Singapore
San Francisco New York South Paulo at
Sydney and the enterprise tier it gets a
few more locations deploys are also
atomic which means that nullify waits
until all the files are published before
pushing everything to production so that
your customers never see like a half
updated site no matter when they hit
when they hit and it also has instant
roll backs which means that it
invalidates the cache Moberly whenever
you do a rollback for example by
clicking an old deploy and clicking
publish deploy so here I have rolled it
rolled the version back and now it's
instantly invalidated and I can just
refresh and see that old deploy lastly
you also get a set optimization now this
is not on by default but it's so easy to
turn on that I can't resist telling you
about it so if you head over to the site
that we've been published and you look
into the sources you can see that we've
actually not optimized this site for
performance this is obviously a super
small site so it doesn't matter but you
may need you may want to have this on a
larger site so for example we can minify
the CSS or also if we had any JavaScript
files we can also modify that and do a
bunch of
hygienic things to clean up the way that
we optimize our assets so if we want to
turn that on head over to deploy
settings and scroll down to post
processing section and we can click on
asset optimization and enable asset on
acid optimization and click Save
and the last step to do in this process
is to head over here and we trigger
deploy
so that will introduce acid optimization
into the post-processing step which is
after you've uploaded all your files and
now when i refresh my site you can see
that the structure of the site puts I
mean it looks the same on the HTML site
point of things but the CSS is now
minified so this is that much faster to
deliver over the wire and it just took
you a couple clicks so we covered some
nice features that you get by default
there may be others that I haven't
covered I just wanted to highlight some
of these and the last part of the deploy
section is going to be about customizing
the URL the domains that your customers
see so the first thing to try is to not
stick to the auto-generated ones that
have been assigned to you but just to
customize what that looks like so over
here I'm gonna say something I can go
over to deploy settings that's a general
and change the site name so over here I
can say
that was my job demo site
so now when I click over here it has a
more ergonomic site name but it is still
on the nullifier com domain another
feature I wanted to highlight is what
happens when you want to customize the
internal URL architecture within your
site so for example let's create an
about Us page and have that show up so
I'm going to create about that HTML
and I'm gonna hollow out most of these
features just call this
about us
and leave the rest
okay so now I have a new about us age
and I'm gonna change to master
and commit this
knew about a speech and push it semester
I can say I can hate to about and see
the about us page so that's all well and
good until we tell people to go to the
about Us page and they might type in
slash about us and get a 404 page it's
not found so what do we do about that
so one of the ways we can handle this is
to add in a redirects file so there's
some guides as to how to how to do that
over here but we'll just show you inside
of code so I'm just gonna add a
underscore redirects file and this
basically just tells you where to
redirect from and to so for example if
people type in about us we direct people
to about so again I'm gonna commit this
and redirects and I'm going to push to
mess so now when I head to this about us
it's going to redirect to about
let's do it again about us it redirects
to about so that's very handy but
sometimes people just type in any sort
of random stuff and they just don't
really get a nice experience so it's
nice to set up a custom 404 page so
let's also do that I'm going to set up
any 404
and
not
okay and I'm also going to set up a
redirect
that's a catch-all so how you do a
catch-all redirect is you just literally
get a start and you direct people to the
404 so if you imagine in a single page
app you might want to send people to
index.html because then the single page
app might redirect people to the right
area but here we're going to send people
so now when i refresh it actually
redirects the 404 on literally an URL
except for about us which the works so
the redirects only run when there's no
corresponding HTML or other static asset
to use for people using javascript and
requesting json files do note that
sometimes you may accidentally hit a
redirect and get back in HTML when you
actually amend to request something in
jason so just be careful about that and
be aware that you're parsing just about
as jason and those that will typically
solve your errors
now of course when you're getting your
site up to production you're probably
also going to want to use a custom
domain so let's head over to settings
headed to the domain management section
and here's what you can configure your
custom domain
nullify offers free custom domains that
doesn't mean it buys the domain for you
but if you already have a domains but
somewhere for example from Google
domains or hover you can actually set it
up to link that site together this is
something that other hosting providers
charge for so for example I can just say
whatever so it's not a oh that's that's
my own site and I can click verify and
if it's already owned by me I can say
yes add domain see what happens
so my site already currently uses this
if it's a site that hasn't been set up
you can you know you can also set it if
you if you have a domain that you want
to buy you can actually buy it through
nullify
and
you can actually buy it through nullify
and now if I wall buy it for you and you
can paper nullify with that
and to set it up for you here's what it
looks like for my personal domain I have
a nullifying sub domain as well as a
custom domain setup that's set to be the
primary domain and everything just
redirects to that primary domain I also
have nullify managed DNS and that's what
notify uses and that's an extra service
and lfi provides to do to add extra
features but anyway so here's how the
DNS panel looks if you have a custom
domains
you can also enable ipv6 as well as
customize your DNS records
and nameservers note that you can manage
all your domains on this team level on
Abdallah final column slash teams slash
your team slash DNA so that's the end of
the first part of this video let's have
a quick recap of what's available to you
with net LeFay when you're deploying
there are four methods of deploying we
started out with notifies historical
method which is dropping dragging and
dropping then we use the CLI to do a
manual deploy then we also link to
linked our repo up to github then we set
up continuous deploy from github so that
every time you push to github you'll get
a new deploy and that is continuous
deployment and finally we set up the
deploy to nullify button on our readme
so that open-source project can clone
our repo and deploy and one-click we
also took a little look at the defaults
that are provided out of the box for
Delphi we get free HTTP also called SSL
we also get free deploy previews same
deal you can also get branch deploys
which I do not cover in this video but
they're kind of the same thing just for
different branches we also talked about
nullify as a CDN how they're distributed
among various points of presence how
notified applies or atomic meaning they
all deploy every single file to
production at once and as well as
providing instant roll backs from a
network control angle we also talked a
little bit about turning on asset
optimization so this is not on by
default but it's pretty much one click
and unless you have some bugs that are
not compatible with this you should
always have it on and finally we talked
about notify and custom domains so most
things are hosted on a custom notify sub
domain but sometimes and sometimes you
want to do redirects around what the
internal URL structure of your pages are
we covered that as well as how to do
catch all's for 404s we also covered how
the link up comes with custom domains as
well as a little bit about nullify DNS
and however if I can manage a DNS for
you if you choose to have it you can
also set a branch
applause for managed DNS if you're using
nullified en er so that's the scope of
deploying an Elif I and in other videos
will cover the other sections but if you
have anything about any questions about
deploying please let me know
Cheers
you
in this video we're going to be covering
part 2 of our series on the other file
and specifically focusing on things that
you should know about building and the
continuous deployment aspect of
so let's drill into that a little bit
more we're gonna cover build tools and
static site generators we'll cover what
build settings are what the build bought
is build stages the different things
that are done during the build while
concurrent builds are and how you can
cancel builds to keep under your
concurrent limit some build gotchas that
people commonly run into as well as what
to think what to do when things go wrong
we'll end with a discussion about
environment variables and the things you
can do to set them in nullifier to
change the deployment environment to
exactly what you need
first let's have a little discussion to
bombed out the fine built tools nullify
is strongly supportive of build tools in
fact one of the founding theses of
nullify is that static site generators
are the next big thing and that
basically came from tracking the
statistics on static site generators and
seeing that people wanted to use them to
deploy to our CDN but they were manually
doing it and we wanted to build in a
continuous deployment tool to help them
build and deploy their sites in fact I
strongly recommend watching this talk by
notify CEO Matt Dillman because it
really explains the benefits of the job
stack compared to what came before it
but anyway we're here to learn about the
build process
so the first thing to understand about
the build process is that you can always
do local builds you may not need
continuous deployment
the problem with continuous deployment
is that it's done remotely it's on
someone else's server and it may
introduce extra hurdles for you when
you're actually trying to just develop a
new feature so if you're doing local
development
don't use continuous deployment just
local locally build and push stuff to
now look fly until you're happy that you
can turn continuous deployment back on
let's take our existing site that we've
been working on from part one and that's
add a build process to it so right now I
have this folder which is a dist folder
and it's got a bunch of index.html files
and let's say I want to add some
JavaScript to it to write some
interactive components what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to add the BART the parcel
bundler so that would be yarn first I
have to initiate initialize the package
star Jason and then I have to add the
parcel bundler
and while that's going on I can also
install react yeah dumb because I'm
gonna use that as well so here we're not
using a static site generator but we're
using it using a build process and
ascetic site generator is just a massive
build process so now we've got the
dependencies installed we're gonna
rearrange this a little bit so I'm gonna
take this this folder and rename it to
source and we're gonna build from the
source to the dist folder and remember
that the the full the folder that we
ultimately publish is the dist folder
all right the next thing I'm gonna try
and do is I'm going to go to this source
folder I'm going to add a new folder
called index dot J yes I'm gonna paste
in some pre-prepared react code
and I'm going to go to index.html and
add a script
that ID equals F and then I'm going to
add a script tag at the bottom saying
skirts
source
so now when I run yarn parcel
so or index dot HTML
I get a nice local server where I can
see the results of my code this is hello
from react and I can actually click an
interactive button so I know that I've
added some JavaScript to my static site
so this is wonderful news and we need to
actually make this run in production so
I'm gonna cancel my breading process I'm
gonna go over to package Jason and make
life a little bit easier for me with
some NPM scripts this is obviously
optional but it's pretty common to set
this up because it's easy to run it so
I'm gonna put in my command again source
index dot okay Mel and I'm going to
introduce a build command as well so
this just has a build again you can use
any process you don't even have to use a
JavaScript build tool but this is just
an illustrative idea to bring you
through the top table so now when I run
your on build it's gonna execute this
command and run parcel build and that
builds to the dist folder and remember
that this folder is exactly what we're
gonna ship to nullify to verify that the
dist folder has built successfully can
use serve just serve as a CLI that you
can install and that serves it files
locally you can see that your your code
is running in production the difference
between this old version and this one
said this is running Reax in development
mode and over here we're running Reax
in production mode
so that's how you can tell that your
builds on fronting locally so as long as
you can develop and build locally you
may not need continuous deployment
because as long as you're debugging
things and making sure that you your
JavaScript code is even valid this is a
perfectly fine way you don't have to use
notify at all
but what nullify does for you is starts
to do that automation step so basically
the idea is that you would not be
checking in your dist
folder you would just be saying you just
be adding that to getting actually
and you only have the source folder in
your code
let's see what happens when we push our
latest changes to get
we can see that our build has failed
because this time we don't have a dist
directory anymore remember we added that
to get ignore because we're now building
from a source directory that means that
we need to run the build command in our
deployment environment to set up
continuous deployment so that brings us
to build settings really there's only
two places to set your build command the
first is in your deploy settings so
let's edit our settings over here and
add the build command
Yaron run build and we're still going to
deploy from dist and we'll save that you
can use the base directory if you have a
subfolder for example if you have a mono
repo setup
so now if the bill command set we're
gonna have to go back to deploys and
rerun the deploy again you can see that
our build is not successful and in
particular you can see that we're now
executing the user command your on run
build which is the one that we did and
it's showing us running the build
showing the output of the build and then
saving a bunch of dependencies and then
deploying site from dist so over here if
you want to check out the deploy you can
open this in a new tab and check out how
this reacts code is now in production on
the production nullify site and it's
using the production build of react so
that's all well and good but there's a
second way to set build command and
that's it nullified tamil this is a
higher priority current so it actually
overrides what we had before so I'm
gonna comment it out and this is how it
should look under the build settings you
should add a command equals and then
whatever string you want to run your own
build so this can take any form
previously we set yarn run build but if
you're using yarn you can also just type
yarn build and that is basically the
same command I just want to show you
some visual difference I'm gonna commit
it to get add build command and I'm
gonna push it to master and that'll kick
off the build again in metal if I notice
that this time there is a special
message printed over here saying there's
different build command detected going
to use the one specified in the Tamil
file yarn build versus yarn run build so
yarn run build is the first command that
we set in the user interface and yarn
build is the second command that we
actually set in nullified amo so this is
higher precedence because that's the
single source of truth for all the
notify settings that you ever want to
build so I personally encourage people
to use normal but you may find it easier
to on board making beginners with the
web UI either way when you read your
logs you should be able to figure out
what's going on by keeping an eye out
for
the commands that you want to run and
looking for any error messages keys
so overall that's a very gentle
introduction to build settings it wasn't
too hard but really what's an operation
over here is the core of nullifier which
is the buildbot
and that's something that we're gonna
dive into a little bit in this next
section
so one way to find out about the bill
bot is to read some of these
documentation on the site it goes into a
little bit about the origin of the bill
bot some default environment settings
and versions that you may want to know
about but basically the high-level
concept that you should know is that the
bill bot is basically a docker container
our CTO used to work at docker and so
we're very familiar with this technology
and it gives us a lot of my security and
reproduction capabilities that is very
helpful in creating the continuous
deployment service like net low fly so
let's check out what the docker
container environment looks like it
really is just a massive bash file this
is entirely open source so you can
actually run it locally so you can debug
your own doctor builds there's different
versions of the build images that are
available so the legacy sites will have
the trusty version you should not run
into that if you're watching this video
and the current sites have the xenial
build image and that's the more current
up-to-date version you can see the
branches accordingly there is ongoing
work on new a new version of the build
bot so by the time you watch this video
there may be a new version available but
hopefully I'll also have a new video out
by day covering that but basically you
should be aware of that you can actually
pull down the production the exact same
docker image then nullify run to your
local environments so that you can test
your builds in case something is going
wrong in this whole build logic and it's
also open source so you're welcome to
contribute but again I want to stick to
the high level if you know that there's
a build pot you know that you can
reproduce it you know that it does a
number of different things but at a high
level you should be aware that there is
a cache so nullify builds are not
entirely stateless they actually we
actually cache things for performance
improvements everything is stored in a
nullify cache directory and in fact you
can you personally can use a build
script
to save things in cash lift them and
decide whether to build things are not
based on the cash you may write your own
scripts or you can use open source
tooling like this one from David Wells
called cash me outside which is pretty
clever I do like the name a lot but
basically it helps to think about house
you to think about checking where do you
store things in cash how should you
handle a cash update and then checking
for gifts between updates and if there
is a need to update the cash then you
run the cash update again so a simple
thing like that can actually cut down
your build times by a lot by skipping
the steps of building things that are
unnecessary for you to build
then I will install Nana buildbot those
two second stages starts installing
dependencies the dependencies here are
not just your you know pack NPM
dependencies but also your known
versions it will check the dot and VM
versions for example it will check your
Ruby environments if you're using a Ruby
static site generator like Jekyll PHP
Hugo so on and so forth yeah even has
Python go a nice grab bag of everything
that you could possibly want
I even have had some success installing
Haskell you can just curl your various
environments and store them in cache
basically anything that you can do in a
typical bash environment you can do in
notify then we get to the actual build
process that's where we run your build
command if you have one obviously we did
the first part of the video entirely
without a build process so you don't
have to have one if you don't need it
then we package and optimize this is an
optimization step that may or may not
apply for you but basically this is post
processing and other optimizations that
we do for delivering to our CDN then
we're going to deploy the site from the
disk folder again this is from the
folder you specified in your net without
Tommo or somewhere else we're gonna save
the dependencies for the next build and
we're gonna output a manifest you can't
see over here but there's a manifest of
what has been produced so that we can do
diffs and so that we can produce images
so that we can produce summary
information like this showing you what
files and what redirect rules have
changed and have been processed by the
bill
so that's the long that's the high level
overview of the build stages things
happen in a sequence and I think if you
know the where your issues are if you're
debugging a build it will help you will
help us a lot in helping you and all
around demystify identified by a lot so
the last thing that we should cover
before getting into the gotcha section
is concurrent builds and cancelling
builds so the idea here is that anything
can trigger a build right I can be
pushing a commit to get or it could be
triggering and deploy over here or I
could be triggering a deploy from a
billhook that we talked about in the
previous video so over here I have a
billhook that I can just be calling
randomly and so there now I have two
concurrent deploys so what's happening
right here is that I only have a maximum
of one concurrent deploy so this is
building and this is waiting sometimes I
actually want to just skip this step
because I just want to go straight to
the most recent build because I know
that's the one and so I can just click
on click in here and cancel the deploy
so once I cancel the deploy I'm no
longer I'm using that concurrent deploy
and now I have the next one in queued so
I just have to wait a little bit but
already it's starting to build so that's
the that's the rough idea if you want to
have for a one for a single person
workflow one concurrent build is
probably enough but you may one for a
team you may want to look into multiple
concurrent builds so that you don't hold
each other up canceling the build is as
simple as just killing the doctor
process and that's so as long as nothing
so as long as everything is failing
every single build is failing the most
recent successful build actually still
keeps alive so so your site doesn't go
down until we have a new successful
build all right so time to cover some
gotchas that people typically run into
in fact this is probably the most
difficult part of learning necklace.i
which is learning how to use a
continuous deployment environment in
fact we have a whole place in the docs
dedicated to build gotchas so
if you have any issues just make sure to
have a read of all of these and see if
that matches your situation so some in
the common gotcha is that I wanted to
highlight is first of all the 15-minute
rule basically if your bill takes longer
than 15 minutes
notify might cut it off on the free tier
if you're a customer or you have some
sort of special case you may get in
touch with support to extend it up to 60
minutes or higher next you also have to
think about permissions and API secrets
sometimes your builds particularly if
you're using a Gatsby or next template
that requires a API key otherwise it
will fail to build then you may need to
provide those API keys in order to build
build stuff we'll have a section at the
end about environment variables where
you can set them lastly I also want you
to be careful about what folder you're
deploying so make sure that when you
have a dist folder you're actually
building to the disk folder sometimes
people just aren't aware of what folder
did the pointing to and just thinking
that through can help a lot and of
course there's a community nullify topic
where you can find out a lot more about
FA cues that people run into on building
things so that really leads me into the
troubleshooting part of the video
basically what to do when things go
wrong make sure to read your build logs
I've already read the bill Logs with you
for a number of different build
situations make sure that you can build
locally so if all else fails at least
make sure you can do your build command
locally like Yarn build for example and
make sure that runs without any hiccups
so that this exact same thing can
actually run in nullify
and then also think about hidden
dependencies so for example over here
I'm using node 10.13 and over and
nullify I'm using 10.16 if there's any
India if there's any differences that
I'm relying on that might actually cause
some very subtle bugs so just to be
aware of that you can set the null
versions in an nvm script and it's all
well documented in the docs next a yarn
reverses NPM issue so for example one of
the very common issues is relying on
yarn and your build for men but then not
having yarn in your build environment
yarn is only installed if you have a
yarn lock file so if I delete this this
will just run this was just assume it's
an NPM setup and the yarn command will
not be available so you need to add a
young lock file for the yarn CLI to be
installed
and that's a pretty common issue for
beginners basically just always commit
your lockfile if you're using Hugo grant
Bower or any other environment like Ruby
or Python definitely head to the build
settings page to check out options for
configuring the versions of your
environment so that you can run the
version that you actually expect and if
all else fails definitely check out
community not nullify comm where you can
probably search your question to be
answered or just follow your own
question the last part of this video
focuses on environment variables where
you can set API secrets and all other
good stuff so basically the only place
to set environment variables as of right
now is inside the user interface so
let's head over to our site go to deploy
settings scroll all the way down to
environment and set environment
variables my secret for example
I'm always I'm gonna save that and now I
can access this if I'm a variable inside
my build process so I'm gonna go in here
and actually try to add that to my build
one way I can do that is to just add it
as a build command as a prebuilt so over
here I can just add pre build and by the
way this is a building feature of NPM
scripts nothing nullify specific here
and let's commit this
so now if we open up our nullified log
again you can now see that inside our
new build we're running the pre-built
script and it echoes the secret that
I've placed inside of my environment
variable so this is handy for open
source projects that may want to ping
private API for example to get some data
to actually pass into the static site
generator so you can build for example a
Shopify site or air table data or
anything else like that now the fire
environment variables are not just for
passing in sequence to your app you can
also use them to change the environment
to vary the environment so you can check
out this list where these are net low
Phi specific environment variables
nullify communicating to you so you can
check for example and process that
vanilla fine if that's true then you're
inside of a note 4 environment if I also
tells you what immutable URL you're
deploying to the main URL that you're
probably gonna access what branch is
coming from if you're deploying from a
different branch the commit the build ID
the context basically a lot of metadata
to figure out what the origin and meta
and meta information about your build is
so that's the first category of
environment variables which are things
that nullify puts in your environment to
communicate to you what is going on in
your environment and the next category
are things that you can set inside of
nullifies environment so that changes
the versions for example you can set the
NPM version you can set the yarn version
or your ruby version gold version
Java version Python version and all that
stuff and so this is extremely variable
and it's all there for you if you need
it there also another category of
environment variables that you should
probably never touch but these are
helpful in case you need them for some
debugging or some magic internal events
things I personally
so if you want to learn more check out
this scotch article that I wrote
detailing how to use environment
variables to pass secrets to in
front-end take note that exposing API
tokens to your front-end is sometimes a
bad thing so reacts view gatsby they all
like to make you prefix your environment
variables to make sure that you're aware
not to leak everything over and then
simple guide as to how to change
environment variables to vary
environment like we already explained
there's also some other power user
features that we talked briefly about
yeah so that's an overall guide to
notify build in aggregate is not too
complex but we combine building with
deploying to verify edge that can be
extremely powerful and in the next video
we'll cover local dev and wonder if I
can do for you there see ya
we're in part three of our entered
natla phi and this is nullified dev
nullified dev is the newest kid on the
block and in fact most of it is still in
beta but it's worth talking about
because it's kind of the newest
functionality and it helps a lot with
your local dev capabilities so the best
way to find out more information about
it is to check out the site natla v comm
slash product slash dev and this gives
you a good overview about what it does
it's a dev server that powers a lot of
the local replication of what the
nullify production platform is and we
just replicate it on your local
environment and the reason you want this
is because remember you want to have
faster iteration cycles and you don't
want to wait for the bill pot so you
want to have full control and local
replication of your builds before you
actually deploy them so the way you get
there is to npm install in the CLI and
then run nella phi dev and this has a
detective mode that will pick up any of
your static site generator projects so
that starts a full local environment it
detects and runs your site generator
makes environment variables available
from the production platform does edge
logic so your redirects will work and
then runs your cloud functions as if as
a function as a local server and we
proxy everything together and then you
can also stream live as well so the best
way to get started is also to head to
the docks
there's a talk that you should
definitely check out introducing
nullified dev this talk happens to be
the keynote at which notify Devas
launched so definitely check that out
and the other thing you should know
about the docks is that it's not the
full story feed and notified of API is
still a little bit in flux and so we've
actually managed that on the CLI repo
and that's you have to just go through
the github no Phi - slash Li Li and you
just look in the readme and look for the
nella 5f docks and here you can get
actually a detailed information about
usage but we're gonna guide you through
it so let's head over to our demo site
that we've been working on and this is
running parcel and it's a it's a project
that we can run so right
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to treat
this as a static site so I'm gonna act
as the build pot and what does the bill
bot do for building this site it doesn't
run the dev server it actually runs the
build command right so let's actually
just run the build command ourselves
I'm gonna run yarn build and that
actually runs parcel build and that
generates to the dist folder you can see
over here and so that's normally what
we'd serve from metafiles point of view
and so now we can actually run nullify
dev so we have that CLI command notify
dev there's that a little gem icon that
I'm very proud of and you can see that
there's no dev server detected it's spun
up a server on localhost 3 999 as well
as a nullified dev server on localhost 8
8 8 8 so there are two different servers
and let's see what the difference is so
now I'm on localhost 8 8 8 8 and you can
see that I have an active react app it
looks good and that's what we've been
working with but also I can go to
localhost 3 999 and get the exact same
thing so I also have a live react app
and so what's the difference why do we
have two different servers and that's
what you really have to understand on
bond nullify is that there's a project
server and then there's a net lafete dev
server so the project server is if it
comes with a server then we'll use that
one if not now if I devil spin up a
server for you and then serve from there
so that's what we've been doing just now
which we saw a static host and it will
join everything and then I'll put a
single unified location so localhost 888
so that about sums it up for the build
process but we also want to preserve the
developer experience of the live hot
reloading dev server so let's take a
look at what parcel does for hot
reloading we run yarn start and it runs
parcel source index.html and then it
outputs and localhost 1 2 3 4 so that's
the important port for them for parcel
it's going to be 1 2 3 4 4 other
projects that create reactive OB others
but we know that for notify devs we can
go into no final tamil and add that
config command so the port will be 1 2 3
4
you can tell now if I do that and you
can see documentation for this in the
notify devdas over there
and that's exactly what we're doing and
then we'll run the we'll add the command
of yarn start that's exactly what we
just did right we ran yarn start and
then we navigated to localhost one two
three four
so we've configured nullified death
inside of nullified Tamil and the final
piece is that we'll want to add a
publish directory this is really where
the redirects file will be located it's
not strictly necessary but it's probably
a good idea to leave it in there I'm
just gonna point it to source doesn't
really matter so now I can run that lo
fight dev and instead of running a
static server for me it's gonna actually
start to run the parcel server for me on
localhost one two three four I'm making
an emphasis in on this because
previously we ran a static server and we
just did yarn build before running our
static server and then serving up our
files locally now we're using nullified
dev to run parcels start or yarn start
which runs parcel and parcel runs a
server at localhost one two three four
so again you'll see that the site can be
accessed on localhost one two three four
and also the nullified dev server can be
accessed at localhost 8 8 8 8 so the
question then becomes why I bother to
servers it's confusing it's seems like
this unnecessary we have local hosts on
a da-a-ate as well as 1 2 3 4 and the
reason is because of this diagram and
this is all the extra functionality we
get to add because we're proxying the
project's original server to 888 and so
when we're the user we actually view
that URL localhost 88 and we get all
this functionality that we would get in
production for example redirects so over
here in my underscore redirects well I
have a redirect from about us to about
and so when I head to localhost 888 8 I
can type in about slash about us and
that redirects to slash about and that
means that our redirects are working
locally and that's important for people
for example in the advertising industry
who really care a lot about broken links
I also want to show you how detectors
work so notice I'm starting from an
empty folder and I'm going to create a
new create react app
that's always very awkward to say and
now when I'm done installing notice how
this is a normal create react type
folder and normally you'd start by
typing yarn start but in and that kicks
off the react scripts start script but
here we're actually going to just run
nullified dev and nullified dev is going
to pick it up that the fact that we're
running a career rack tap project and
then it'll just run automatically and
pick it up so that's the vision of
create react app and detectors and
nullify that nullify dev will just
detect your project and it will just run
the server automatically without any
configuration now we're going to good a
quick demo of how environment variables
work in lfi dev and you can pull down
your production environment variables to
local dev obviously you shouldn't always
do that but it can be very helpful for
debugging and not duplicating some
environment variables so first I'm gonna
run a yarn build and because I don't
have this new projects link something
that if I
I'm gonna run nullify in it and because
I don't have it linked to github I'm
just gonna choose the create deploy site
and manually option and it's just gonna
create a site instance for me that I can
deploy to so now I'm just gonna create a
nella file tamil file and that's gonna
house all the settings which I normally
would setup
so first up add in a build key with a
publish value of build and the other
command I'm gonna run is just nullify
deploy - - prod and so now because I'm
just gonna publish that build folder
that's all I need to know and now I'm
deployed my crate react app app is
deployed without continuous deployment
but now I can run something like Nell if
I open and head to the deploy section
and head to the environment variable
section and add in an environment
variable here I'm using everybody's
favorite environment variable my
underscore secret but that's actually
not going to work in a reactor because
create react app doesn't want you to
expose every environment variable on the
front end so they have this filter then
you must prefix all your environment
variables with react app underscore and
then whatever your environment variable
so those are the ones that will actually
get exposed on the front end and that's
a very good security feature but it just
trips up people who don't know that it
exists and they have to look in the
ducts so now we can actually reference
that environment variable inside of our
code so here I'm just gonna ask access
process and not react app my secret and
that's gonna be available in production
so typically what you do here is you try
to have a duplicate and env file locally
and then run that but here when I run
that lafete dev I can just or I just run
nd because I'm my shortcut I just I can
just run the dev server but then also if
you look at the bill dogs it also
injects this build setting of
environment variables so now the Phi dev
goes up to to my nullifier instance
pulls down that secret and now locally I
haven't deployed yet locally I have
access to that production environment
variable so that's the idea and that can
be extended to do a lot of different
things together
for example integrations with add-on
providers I'm gonna do a video on that
as well but just trivially you can
replicate your production environment
with environment variables and redirects
you can also share them live with notify
- - live but that's very beta so I'm not
gonna show it to you today and the other
thing that we're going to talk about is
also not exposing your secrets so here I
have a secret that I want to work with
but I don't want to expose it to the
front end but you still have to work
with it in some form so if example like
an API secret then I want to hide
somewhere right like I don't want the
user to know it because then they can
also just use my functions so I'm going
to show you the nullifier functions
create command you can type it out as
part of the CLI so obviously we're just
gonna use nullify functions called and
create but obviously you can also use a
alias for that I use NFC and that just
runs that command oh I don't have a
functions folder so I'm just gonna go
ahead and go to nullify Tommo
and add a function folder you can call
it the very creative name of functions
but you can just really call it whatever
you like and now I'm gonna run the five
functions created again and notice it
created that functions folder and now it
gives me this drop-down
things I can choose from so there's a
whole bunch of pre-made templates for
you to get started
depending on your use case here we're
really just going to go through and
maybe pick something like this hello
world function that I've picked out and
that really scaffolds out that template
into your functions folder that you've
configured by default mattify dev gives
you a folder and then a script under
that folder which is named the same and
it follows the AWS lambda syntax and so
now I can rename my secret to just my
seeker because I'm not gonna expose it
to the front end and I can take that my
underscore secret and expose and grab it
in process T and V inside of my net
low-five function so here I have a
co-located with my source code but I'm
just gonna say process the MV my secret
and I'm just gonna echo it out in a JSON
body response so now I'm gonna run
nullified dev and that again thinking
about your mental model runs that create
react app server but then also runs a
nullified function server so it's under
the URL dot nullify / function / hello -
world and now that response
hello I'm always angry that's the exact
response from the environment variables
so we've now shown you how to access
environment variables from the front end
as well as via functions and that's very
helpful so for example when I create a
hook or a fetch data when I load my app
and when I when I load my app I can just
head back to the front end and that's
gonna hang my function
and let me just open up the dev tools
over here so I'm gonna open my app and
it's gonna ping my function and so it's
not gonna expose that environment
variable on the front end it's going to
just ping that nullifies function and
the function itself has access to that
environment variable now obviously this
is a very simple function and if you
look at the code it's actually we've
aired on this the side of very simple
simplicity just to show you that you
really don't need that much to get going
we've even included some boilerplate
like caching and returning in a status
code of 500 if there's an error and
that's just a best practice for HTTP
status codes but here we're gonna
introduce a more complicated function
and this time one that uses known
modules dependency for itself so again
we're gonna run our five functions
create I'm gonna pick the node fetch
template and node fetch itself installs
non modules with a package jason and
then it uses that as a fetch inside of
known to ping an api so this is a more
realistic nullified function or service
function which proxies an api for you so
here I'm gonna run I'm gonna ping the
note fetch in front of in my front end
and then run notify dev and now when I
reload my friend and it actually loads
that external API and so now it's
proxied so that I can bypass course
issues for example or I can add secret
API key or I can add several functions I
can read a database and really just
whatever you want to do in known you can
do in in node.js functions subject to
the timeout limits so here for example I
can add my process DMV top my secret and
if that was required by the API
I couldn't definitely send it in there
without exposing it to my front-end so
that is probably the number one support
question and now you know how to do that
I can also swap it out so for example I
here I have a different API and I'm
swapping enough for Chuck Norris jokes
always a good time but hopefully you get
the idea that I'm developing all this
very very quickly
inside of my local dev environment
and it's exactly the same environment as
it would be in the service scenario I
can even test it for example if I open
up a new terminal and type notified
functions invoke that will give me a
list of my existing functions and I can
pick that one of the functions like
hello world I can choose whether I want
to emulate nullify identity we'll talk
about this in another video I'm gonna go
with no for now and and that would that
would basically pass a authentication
header if I need to but here we get the
mock response so without even running
your front-end I can test my mind
nullify function and so that's a very
good example for more information
definitely read the readme expect for
example for passing a sample payload
query string as well as a file that has
that payload we do have special case
event triggered functions we're not
really going to cover that right now but
eventually good functions are basically
hard-coded names that are triggered on
certain events like for example when
someone signs in through nullify
identity and that's useful to know
important thing to know is to understand
what happens when I have my nullify
functions continuously deployed so for
example here am I getting norm on the
folder uh file I have the node modules
get ignored so that means that when I
deploy my files in nullifies buildbot
the node modules for the node fetch
function will not be there and that will
be a problem because it would try to
require the node fetch module and it
will fail so here I have an example of
such a failure and it says for example
error could not find non fetch module in
the file and so a lot of people run into
this and think it's a bug with nullified
dev it's not really it's it's also a
little bit our fault that we can make
this experience a bit nicer but really
the the solution is to make sure to
install to run the NPM install or yarn
on each individual function folder if
you need it
obviously if you don't need it you can
just put everything in the top-level
node modules and that's the standard
known resolution algorithm but one
solution to you actually use is to add
the file lambda
so this is a helper library it used to
be the predecessor to notify dev and
that's why you see some old information
about this but now notify lambda is to
help our library for Anila find eV and
you will ad will use the Annette will
find lambda install thing and we'll just
add it as a post install NPM script so
now that will run and you'll go through
every single function folder and it will
it will just install the dependencies
for every functions for there and you
can read more in the docs but
essentially this is what the success
will look like we can see somewhere in
the dogs that will have a net Liffe
ilambda install command being run and
you'll say it's installing function
dependencies and node fetch dependencies
are installed so that's the kind of
thing that we are looking for for a
continuously deployed service nullify
function solution with no dependencies
all independently managed per folder and
that's a that's a really good way to
handle the dependencies because it will
just guarantee that it's always
installed and so here you can see the
same app that we built in dev in
production and if it was working exactly
the same if you notice all of these
functions that we've be written written
so far is in node.js format with the
exports that handler syntax or module
dot export syntax and if you want to use
webpack Babel or typescript you can't
really do that here without a build step
right this is raw no js' it runs under
node 8 or 10 and you really need a build
step and that's where you use nullify
lambda so now if I don't know if I'd
ever have similar but overlapping
responsibilities and I wrote a lot of
Doc's in the readme to explain how to
use them but basically no fair lambda is
a build tool now that runs your nullify
functions from a source to a dist
and that's the basic understanding that
you have to achieve here now now this
these functions will be your source file
and you're gonna have to serve or
publish the functions from a dist folder
so so here we can actually move
everything so for example I can create a
new function folder called source slash
functions and I can move this function
this hello old function
to a typescript function I I can also
just like rename everything so I'm gonna
I'm gonna add some typescript types so
for example I can follow the docs and
add babble preset types good yarn add
dash D that will preset high script and
I can also add a bunch of other utility
is like typescript types node and types
AWS lambda and that just helps to add
typescript to my projects here I'm only
gonna use it for the hello world
function but you can see everything I'm
about to do so I'm adding a babel RC
file and so we're using typescript with
babel and now in hello Walt yes I can
import the types for importing and the
handler context callback in the API
gateway type from AWS lambda so now I
can type and go through and type
everything and I can also use the export
keyword and that's a very very handy
handy way of typing everything so now I
can type for example API gateway events
for events and contexts for context and
now each of these things have the
correct properties on them so for
example if I had type event dot it gives
me all those values from the
autocomplete
because the types that are just from
definitely types of a degree as lambda
the same thing for context including an
identity field which we can use for
nullified entity and and so that's that
these are just very handy ways of
writing better more correct code if you
are okay with using a build step and
using typescript and so now we need to
impose a build command I'm gonna put it
on the post build part of NPM scripts
it's gonna run now if I land up build
source function so it's gonna build from
the source functions into the production
publish the the folder that we gonna
publish like functions hello world and
that's gonna be hello world Jas right
and and that's gonna be a minified
output from the source type script file
and so that's what never fly lambda does
it helps you install dependencies and it
helps you build from a source file to a
disk file and and so then everything can
be can be run locally nullified EV has
an understanding of what know if I
lambda
so it will run that if I land to build
for you if it detects it in your package
scripts so this is what we call function
builder detectors and that's that's
exactly how it how it's supposed to work
so that you can run it locally and make
sure that your scripts are up-to-date
but then also deploy them with minimum
configuration so that is nullified dev
we're gonna go to the next part to
identity forms analytic CMS all that
good stuff but thank you for taking the
time to check out nullify dev and
hopefully that helps your local dev work
okay so now we're on to forms this is
actually a pretty big section it's one
of the most widely used add-ons of nella
Phi and it's meant for what it says on
the tin for form submissions it's not a
database although it does store data so
don't try to use it as a database
because it will cost you and also it's
just not meant for that in terms of the
data structure that it that offers but
it's very handy for contact forums like
if you want to inquire about prices or
if you want to book a workshop or
something or you know leave a comment or
upload a file for example for claiming
receipts or something like that all
these are very good use cases for net
low Phi forms so where to find out about
that low Phi forms
we're gonna go over to the docs and head
to the form section and forms are
literally adding an attribute onto a
form tag as far as regular HTML goes I
do think it's a little bit more
complicated for react forms and we'll
talk a little bit about how that works
in react but in plain HTML we can
actually do this pretty easily in our
demo that we've been working on so I'm
going to go over to the demo that we
have
and I'm gonna go over here so right now
I have all this bunch of stuff actually
I'm just gonna go over to the about so
let's put the forums on the about page
so you can see right now I don't have
any forms I just have a bunch of header
and HTML and then let's go over to the
job demo site
drop notify jump demo site master it
okay let's go over to the forms and see
that here the documentation here's some
basic info and there's nothing here
because there's no forms activated so
what I'm gonna do is I'm literally going
to copy and paste this example down
inside of the about Us page and I'm
going to say this is the Contact Us page
because I just like to name things what
they do so I'm gonna call this contact
dot HTML and now because I have a build
step from source to dist I have to say
yarn build basically just following my
own build command down in here I covered
this in the previous video
and I can now deploy I like deploying
locally and not using the continuous
deployment when I'm debugging something
like a forum so that I can do the builds
locally and just be very very sure what
I'm building because sometimes your
static site generator mine's shrivelled
some values here we just really want to
make sure that we have an elephant AG so
if i refresh I should be able to see
something different
I should see the form name contacts
because I specified the notify tag and I
should see that it's got no submissions
right now so let's have a look at what
it looks like on the current deployed
site I'm gonna go over to the contact us
page and here I'm gonna say hello free
code camp obviously you want to put a
validation on this before sending oh
well there we go so by default it sends
us to this Thank You page which it's
just a default nullify page and you can
customize that later we'll just show you
in a separate section but you can see
over here if you head to the form
section and you hit here that you see
the form submission down in here as well
let's go ahead and attach file
submissions to this form I'm going to
just duplicate this and call this file
you must have an input type of file
that's the semantic HTML and then we can
just call this whatever you want like
FCC file and we'll save that again I'm
going to yarn build
and push
[Music]
Lia's for another fighter ploy
so I just changed the form but because
it's the same name it's gonna still
reflect us the same form
over here and it's still reflected that
but it's got a new field here for FCC
file so let's go ahead over here and
refresh it form to form at every code
Capcom let's pick a file let's send a
little image
than that up there thank you submitted
and when we refresh we should be able to
see form two and a link for the file
that was submitted so this is an image
but obviously it could be something else
as well
now this Thank You page is kind of ugly
so let's actually change that to reflect
something that reflects our the look and
feel of our site and we'll head over to
the project will copy over this contact
HTML and we'll say thank you dot HTML
blah blah blah
thank you
thank you
and take that out
all right
so going to want to link to that
somewhere or build that somewhere so I
will just refer to that in index.html
and then the other step not to forget is
to add an action to the form so I'm
gonna add an action and I'm gonna say
just head to the Thank You page after
you're done submitting okay so I think
that's ready I'm gonna yarn build again
I'm doing manual deployments because I
don't want to wait for continuous
deployments I want full control over
everything so do not continuous deploy
all right so I'm gonna refresh and I'm
gonna say try three potato tomato
whatever and I'm gonna choose the gem
reptiles image I'm gonna send that in
it's gonna submit and it's gonna
redirect and say thank you right or you
could redirect to the index page or
whatever so over here I received the
submission again okay so that's all well
and good and now we have a basic working
flow the next thing you're gonna want to
do is probably to do something else on
submission so right now when you're
submitting your forms you don't really
know about them they're just there and
you have to kind of check for them you
can actually opt to get an email when
people submit forms to you you can add
notification you can add slack
integrations and email or outgoing web
hook to anything that is listening for a
web hug so that's that's an option as
well I should probably put that in there
as one of the options but then what I
wanted to make clear is that you can
also create functions that do whatever
you want including form validation so
everything here is client-side but what
if you need to do server-side form
validation do you need a server
obviously the answer is no because we're
net Liffe I and here's how to do it
we're gonna declare a function folder
down in here I'll just call the
functions folder the very imaginative
name of functions and we'll put that it
will create that functions folder
I actually have another fight dev alias
for this or template for this so I'm
gonna use nullify functions create and
I'm going to look for these submissions
created template so I'm gonna let
nullify dev scaffold that out for me so
what this does submission created is it
runs when a submission is is being done
and it parses that email and it sends
stuff out we're gonna dramatically
simplify this so that we can actually
just try doing something with our event
triggered function which is this is what
it's called this is a special special
name in the docs where it just fires
when people submit forms so we're gonna
parse the event body and payload we're
gonna console.log it out
and it's an Emmy json.stringify this
thing and then we're just going to
return a body that reflects some measure
of success I am going to just return
something like a status code 200 and and
actually I'm just gonna say okay all
right so very very simple function a few
lines of code and we're just logging out
what we receive and we'll see what
happens there
okay so now we can just know if I deploy
again notice I don't have to build the
front end because all I'm doing is
working with the functions so now this
has discovered the function and it's
deploying the function as well if you
want to see the function over here you
can actually head to the functions
section and refresh and you can see that
there's a summation creative function
and there's a log for this function so
now we're gonna submit another form try
number four same potato potato we're
gonna submit it again but now it's gonna
fire and and it might take a while but
we will actually see the logs here so
the idea is that everything that was
submitted you can actually access
including some nice metadata that you
can use and send it off to whatever
other service that you're using so here
we've got a subscription newsletter
thing but this is literally as flexible
as you want you can obviously set up
your own slack integration or Twilio or
whatever you can think of just from the
event of someone submitting a form for
you and obviously you still have the
form data over here so now that anyone
can send in a form to your site the
immediate question is how do we make
sure that they're legit and not spam
submissions and that is the question of
spam filtering we're gonna cover three
methods and the first one is the best
because it takes no configuration you
already have it on by default and that's
your kismet filtering and Akismet is
what WordPress uses for managing
anti-spam they measure it against other
ongoing spam activity and help you
actively block them it's hard to test
them because it's kind of amorphous but
we can actually try with some of these
hard-coded names which are guaranteed to
be spam and let's just try and submit
them and see what happens
so we'll submit them over here and when
we refresh we don't see them show up in
the verified submissions because they're
over in the spam submissions and you can
review them and either delete them or
mark them as verify
and once they're verified they'll show
up
the next method we want to address is
the honey pot so the honey pot is a
security method we're basically checking
BOTS into filling out fields which
humans would not see and you can hide
those fields with CSS so we'll check
we'll try this on this honeypot field
over here and here's how you kind of do
it in the docs but basically if you go
over to your contact form and let's put
in a hurry pot fill that I'm just gonna
copy and paste this field paste it in
there and so this the idea is that this
will be hidden and we can add in a style
tag for example
that hidden
opacity
zero
and then the last thing to do is to tell
nullify that this is a honeypot field so
anything the name bought field is a
honeypot field so we'll just tell
nullify that and okay
now we'll yarn build again and nullify
deploy so the idea is that you have
extra spam prevention enabled by
honeypot field that's a new indication
that it's on and it's kind of hard to
devil because it just works but I'm
gonna try anyway
so let's actually just use the form and
here you can see the opacity zero field
obviously you can move it around with
CSS or shrink it or whatever doesn't
really matter but here let's just say
human at human I'm human and human at
human calm and send that in and we
should see human at human calm show up
over here it's a fantastic and now let's
actually say robot and not totally human
calm and that's actually fill in that
field we're not supposed to feel it so
the idea is that as a human you never
you never see this feel so you never
fill in but as a robot you're filling in
fields in discriminately so I'm totally
human alright so there's a field here
and we're gonna send that in and let's
see the network tab
I'm gonna send that in and and you can
see in the post request that we send
that in the bot field it's actually
filled out so that means that when nella
file receives it they know that that
field is supposed to be screened out so
it just doesn't even show up when you
refresh and that's one way of spam
prevention via honeypot field it doesn't
even show up into Spanish submissions
just because we know for sure it's spam
great so that's the second method and
then the third method is recaptures so
adding a recapture is pretty much the
same as adding a honeypot except that it
has a different method of catching spam
and this one it imposes more work on
humans but has a higher chance of
success of filtering out spam so the way
you do it is over here if you scroll
down to the reCAPTCHA section and you
literally add a recapture field so let's
just add it in over here
Terk code
but firm and will also tell the forum
and there is a recapture field
mm-hmm so this is the most secure forum
there has ever been
we're gonna build and deploy again so
when i refresh there's a recapture field
obviously it could be styled better but
you can kind of fill it in and that's
intentionally fail the reCAPTCHA
it's just not letting me do
[Laughter]
so yeah I can't really fake being a
robot No
so it's that good that even though I'm a
human trying to simulate being a robot I
just have to be good enough a computer
vision to let it through and now it's
through and I can see myself my own
submission and yeah so it is a little
bit more annoying but that's recaptured
for you and you're pretty much
guaranteed that it's not a robot and
that's also v2 so you should know the
difference between we captured v2 and v3
v v2 is the one with the annoying
picking of stuff there is recatch
overview on settings so you can set up
your own recapture secrets over here
you're using nullifies and recapture v3
is the new one without image selection
it's invisible and supposed to be low
friction and you'd have to set up set
that up yourself with JavaScript but if
you're worried about user friction this
is the way to go so we've talked about
spam filtering and I just wanted to
address one of the important nuances
that a lot of developers face with
modern JavaScript frameworks and that's
with single page apps and let's just
talk a little bit about how we're doing
the form processing here so when you
deploy you can actually see that here
I'm doing manual deploys but it's the
same principle I deploy for my CLI or
from github whatever and once it built
and and pushes all the HTML out there's
this post-processing step that happens
and that's where the forms are detected
what no-fly is basically doing and
saying OK out of all of these generated
files let's zoom out a little bit out of
all these generated files in the dist
folder which of these are HTML and it
looks like this one is HTML ok and let's
look at all of these fields and look for
a foreign field with the nullify tag
right and then I'm just gonna scan this
in as as a form the problem with this
is that sometimes the form doesn't exist
as a single page app so sometimes you
just have like div ID equals app and
that's all you ship for create react app
so that's a common problem and there a
number of ways to do this
so what happens in this scenario where
there's no form in the HTML is that Nell
if I would just tell you that it hasn't
detected any forms and therefore you
doesn't set up the form for you on the
backend so you need to tell nella Phi
that there is a form and so what the
trick is to that is that instead of this
div ID app you can basically take the
app form field name and put it inside of
the div id app
and then paste it in there
and so this way
scan HTML and find the find the form
name set up the fields and then react
we'll come in and replace everything
inside of div id app and you know use
its own JavaScript created elements that
look exactly the same as this thing so
because this is really important for
people to understand we're actually
gonna go through the actions and
actually do this and just to make really
really clear how this is done so that
when you run into your own single page
app scenario I don't care what framework
you're using the same principles apply
it has to exist in the final HTML and
then you can do whatever you want on the
JavaScript side of things and we'll talk
about some Ajax form submissions as well
so over here remember in our initial
video we actually replaced index dot
HTML with some JavaScript index JSO ver
here I'm gonna take that out and move it
over to the contact form so the contact
form is now going to have the JavaScript
and the JavaScript is going to look for
an ID of app and say hello from react so
let's do that
and I'm gonna say ID actually no that's
let's put this put this here div ID
equals app
and we'll look to close the dev here
okay so let's start this and let's see
how that works so reacts so this will be
in the HTML but reacts will come in and
replace everything inside div id app
so it's head to the forum and you can
see that little flash of the forum but
as the JavaScript came in now it became
a react app so the whole idea is that I
have to replicate what's in here with
the with the react stuff so once there's
one version of this in here and if in
the end of in the HTML and then the
other one inside of the forum all the
classes have to be class names
so there's the forum now from react
right and and if you're a Gatsby or
other static site generator user you're
gonna be yelling at me saying you should
probably just instead of duplicating
between HTML and JavaScript right and
having the same form in both why not
just statically generate from JavaScript
I'll tell you what I agree with you so
let's install Gatsby and see how that
works so yaar an IDI ATS B and we're
going to just make a very simple Gatsby
page so pages and we'll say something
like my Gatsby dot J s
Gatsby formed jsy not so will render
this and will export this by default
we'll see what happens when we add a new
script
like Gatsby build or build Gatsby
you can name it whatever you like I'm
just
relying on convention so now we've
Gatsby installed and I have the Gatsby
page set up it's gonna ignore all this
HTML stuff it's which is fine for me if
I have the Cassie page set up let's see
what it built for me so I ran Gatsby
build and by the fall Gatsby builds to
the public folder not the dist folder
and you can change that in the Gatsby
config it's up to you but I wanted to
make sure to go through this exercise
because it's important to know that yes
you save the duplicate action from just
writing in JavaScript and then letting
that generate your HTML so that no if I
can scan the HTML and and set up your
form for you but you do need to know
some caveats so that's why I'm here
so in the public folder this is all the
generated stuff that you're gonna deploy
right and inside a gas reform it's
generated an index dot HTML and inside
that index.html we see what we expect to
see which is a full HTML thing with all
the scripts and stuff and that's great
and the form so now if I can read this
but it's missing one important thing
which is a very important attribute and
if you see over here it says hello from
react and then but it doesn't have the
you know the read the reacts code
because that they'll be hydrated later
and as it's got this form it's got all
the right fields except for one which is
gonna cause you know amount of annoyance
until you figure it out so I'm here to
save you that time which is got the
recapture field it's got the honeypot
feel it's got the action field but it
doesn't have the Nuttall of five field
so right over here and that's because
gatsby by default strips unrecognized
fields and that's why i know if i
actually recognizes both the data -
version as well as the non data -
version and forgets be and for a lot of
webpack and like create react app and
other build tools they wanna they want
to strip away stuff that is it going to
be used
as far as they know in production so
they strip away at the nullifier tag so
we need to make sure that that does show
up so I'm gonna make sure that I'm going
to change this to data and now if I and
make it true so and I'll save this as my
Gatsby form in my react page and I'll
rerun my build and now when you see the
generated HTML just make sure to check
that the form does show up with the
right tag and and then all will be happy
alright so we're going to switch from
Gatsby issues it gets me another static
site generator issues just remember that
they might strip out stumps and stuff
and we're gonna switch back to the
regular single page app code because
that will pretty much behave exactly the
same in Gatsby or in a single page app
thing like crate react app and now let's
take a look at this form and the
subsequent action of redirecting to a
thank-you page this may not be what we
want in terms of user experience like
let's say we submit this form and it
goes in notice that it redirects to a
different page here locally it's
redirecting to the home page instead of
the Thank You page because that's all we
serve but that's still the point remains
that maybe you want to stay on the same
page so let's talk about that so if
that's what you want then you're gonna
have to submit it through JavaScript
instead of a default HTML form
submission so we're in our react app and
we're gonna have to write some submit
handlers to handle that submission so it
will be something like cons handle
submit
it takes an event and we can call it
event prevent default and the forum will
have a target and the forum will be the
target of the event and so the the whole
idea is you prevent the default
submission of the form via regular HTML
and then we handle everything in
JavaScript and update the state
accordingly so for example I can have a
message that updates like that
you
and I'll just make this
I'll display a message something like
message message if not I'm going to show
hello from react
and then I'll just paste in some fetch
boilerplate so basically we have to
replicate all the the functionality that
we would typically get and as well as
grab all the names of every input field
and just submit those values for this
example that I copied it's assuming
controlled values meaning that there is
some state that you can just spread into
the body but here you can also do
uncontrolled reacts components and I'll
assume that you already know how to do
those so I'm just going to fill in the
rest of it by going form that name value
so email
the value
okay so then we'll have the will send
the submission to the end point and then
on success we will navigate if assuming
we have a router library which we don't
in this in the setup but assuming you
have a router library we'd navigate by
getting by going to the attribute of the
form which is the action and so that's a
that's the kind of cheap way to simulate
that but here we're assuming that we
want to stay on this same page after
submission so we don't actually need
this navigation and we don't need the
action the action field as well so I'm
gonna remove that just to make clear
that you don't need it so I go to down
to the forum this is only for the
regular HTML like after submission
navigation so I'm going to delete that
and now I'll say something like set
message success
and that should refresh accordingly
before we forget we should also I should
also mention that this encode command is
a nice little wrapper around the form
data API inside of the browser and you
can also use this on the server if you
want just look for the relevant NPM
package and adjusting codes things
properly so that people know so that
know if I knows it's a form and then
don't forget to wire up the submit
handler
so that's all you need for wiring up the
react app and so locally we don't have
the form endpoint at the back so we
can't really test it that much apart
from just sending it in and then seeing
that there's an error because it's a 404
when you post that message but we can
actually build
build and deploy
so when we go to the production site and
try this out again
hello ajax ajax at potato comm send it
in we can actually control the state of
the forum and stay on the same page and
do everything within react but in the
backend we can actually see the form
submission come in and says hello ajax
so the next section is going to be about
password protection and we'll base
access control and and this is this is a
very very broad base CDN level
protection for your content for your
site and so let's look into what that
looks like so if you head into settings
and you look into access control
and see that this is available in pay
plant but what I'm going to do is I'm
going to transfer this over to a
different team so that we can actually
see what this paid plan looks like and
now when I head to access control I can
see this password and I can set a
password so a simple password like
password
oops
and that's a that's a nice password over
there and what that looks like is simply
a password control down in here and so
especially for internal sites that
you're building for your coworkers
you can just supply something like this
the a SS wrd and have password based
access control we actually do this a lot
inside of nullify for private sites and
for more fine-tuned JWT based access
control where you can have role based
access control you can set the JWT
secret you can definitely check the docs
for more of that information but
basically this involves using a
third-party authentication provider like
off zero or octa and they can
authenticate your jwc secrets and you
can say only Emmons are allowed to view
this page and you can set it in the
redirects file so you can limit it just
to admins and everyone else will get the
404 so that's how you do it
with robust access control definitely
hit up our support if you need to enable
this for your company for everyone else
you can actually take advantage of the
nullify identity service which are going
to move on to next
okay so the difference between access
control and identity is that access
control is restricting access from the
CDN level and identity is for a typical
login logout situation on the client
side so let's go and enable identity and
that's a pretty simple operation we're
going to go over to the identity section
and hit enable identity and we're
enabled and that's pretty simple and
let's now figure out how to let's just
play around my identity a little bit so
the best way to play around with it is
to head over to the enough identity
widget Docs and actually go to the live
demo and let's just get a sense of what
this does before actually using it so
here's a static page and we've got a
single simple button here we click it
and that gives us this widget that's a
modal and we can fill in some
information or we can sign up and login
so let's just go through the signup flow
six one two three six plus one two three
so that's going to send a confirmation
message to my email
and I'm gonna go to my email and so in
my email I get this standard thing this
can can be customized but we're not
gonna go over that and I'm just gonna
click customize your or confirm my email
address and I'm logged in and and that
redirects me back to the original page
remember I have this original page so I
can shut that instance down and this is
the one where I'm already automatically
logged in and when I click outside you
can see that in the in the root of the
page outside of the modal I can access
that information now you can also see
that information on the console I think
we log it out and this is what's
available to you inside of JavaScript in
particular together with the JWT token
with with all your information and
logins that you're gonna use but also
with things that you sign up with like
your full name there's also the
there's also that's a single button
where it's got sign up and log in on the
same modal but some in some designs you
may wish to have multiple buttons with a
sign up and log in on a different button
and that's really just up to you how do
you how you want to configure it it's
it's pretty configurable as well so here
it goes to sign up and here it goes to
login and that's that's a pretty handy
model obviously this is entirely open
source so if you need to style it you
can actually customize the Styles
yourself but you know you can just fork
it as well I'm also going to show you
how we can authenticate with one of the
social off providers I'm gonna
authenticate with Google and it's it's
got my email please don't spam me but
then also it's got some extra metadata
from Google for example my avatar so I
could I could have rendered this and see
my see my github avatar okay so that's
the demo we're gonna learn how to apply
it onto our working widget thing and for
that you should look at the docs
there is the script tag way and then
there's the NPM way so we'll check out
the script tag way first I'm not super
keen on showing everything else because
if you're a Java Script ER you should be
able to figure it out but maybe you
might be getting getting stuck on
something so that's why I'm here right
so I'm gonna do this on my index.html
page
and I'll drop the script tag up here and
then add a div down in here as well
let's just do a top
okay
so let's try this locally
you
so that is a simple button that says
login with nullified entity
then it asks us for the development
instance so I'm on localhost it doesn't
know what notify instance I have so over
here remember when I enabled nullify
identity I've it's on this particular
site so I should just take this instance
and drop it in here I think I need the
HTTP and then I'll set it so yeah that's
uh and now it's telling me it's in local
dev and I can do the same sign up and
login dance as well but I let's say I
want to turn off that confirmation email
workflow and that's that's what we're
gonna cover in terms of the setting so
here I'm allowing signup but I can I can
equally say alright I don't want people
to sign up by one I don't want any Tom
Dick Harry to sign up I just wanna
invite only sign ups so now when i
refresh this project and i try to log in
it only gives me a login option and
there's no sign up option so in order
for to sign people up I have to go into
the to the invite page to the identity
page and invite users and then type in
their emails and then they can sign up
so that's a that's a much more sort of
locked down version of identity
obviously I don't use that to offer for
demos but when you want to let's say
invite only after people have paid you
that's that's the way to do it
so I'm going to toggle that back to open
and the other the other thing I wanted
to talk about also is confirmed versus
not confirmed so that's all the way down
here here's where you can customize the
templates for that are that gets sent
out for email templates but here in
particular is where you want to turn off
the auto confirm so allow users to sign
up without verifying an email address so
good and now when I again i refresh this
locally and I try and login I can now
sign in six six one two three four five
and now if I calm whatever I'll do them
you had a plus to this and it just logs
me indirectly there's no confirmation
step so that's good for sort of less
secure identity use cases where you just
want to you know get people on board as
quickly as possible and then the last
thing that you want to know about in the
settings is the social providers so
external providers therefore that come
by default with nullify their open
issues forum or you can contribute that
if you want to help out an open source
but these are things that we Sui set up
for you
and you can obviously set up your own
with via OAuth and functions that's just
gonna add Google by default you can use
them nullifies version and that's
totally fine or you can use your own
APIs credentials and that just involves
adding a bunch of secrets and stuff and
I'm gonna add it and github as well
these are the two I usually use and
obviously feel free to add the other two
if you need them but what that
translates to is nullified entity is
going to read those settings and and
then offer those as login solutions so
these don't directly redirect back to
your localhost so what happens here is
when I click this it goes to github and
in github tells response with
confirmation and then nullify redirects
the user to the production site and so
that might be a little bit tricky to
test but just as long as you're aware
that it's redirecting you to the
production site you should be good to go
from there
it also takes this access token and if
for example the widget was installed on
this production site yes the the widget
will also strip this access token from
the URL and log you it so just so you
know you can take that access token and
swap it out or take the production URL
and swap it out for your localhost so
localhost one two three four for example
four here and that will log you in
s-six Edna and that's that's just the
nullified entity widget taking over for
local development to do anything
interesting with the login information
you probably want to use JavaScript to
do that so let's look at how to add the
nullify down any widget to our react app
so far what I'm gonna do is going to
import the react script into index.html
and then I'm gonna get rid of this
script just because now we're using the
NPM imports you can see the docs over
here on how we're going to do that so
we're not going to use to see the end
based import anymore
and we can get rid of this button
so now if we reload we should see our
react app embedded inside of our page
and that's great okay and now let's uh
try and import nullify identity from
nullify identity
widget
we
set up and the docs should give you a
clear idea of what it's required you can
basically run notify identity in it and
that should basically be a good enough
setup and then we're going to call the
login function so basically I'm gonna
add a new button button something and
then that would be a login button so
let's write the click Handler and I'll
click equals to know if identity dot
open and that's the open modal and then
we'll register a callback once a login
event happens we'll take the user and
we'll say some we'll just say some sort
of welcome like console dot
console
log welcome user okay
and now let's use that button
on click equals login
all right so that should give us a nice
little login thing but then also log out
a welcome page so let me log out again
and I'm going to login
it says welcome over here twice because
there's two logon events that are firing
but it doesn't matter you can now see
the full information inside of
JavaScript and you can render it so for
example you can say something like
user
and user dot user metadata
dot full name
says user is not defined oh right okay
so in order to get access to this user
outside of the scope of the hand the
click handler you do need to say user
equals to nullify identity dot current
user
and that should give you a nice little
show up your name when you're logged in
and it will show nothing when I log out
I may need to trigger a refresh there
you go
anyway so I trust that you're able to
build a full react app from there with
all the authentication pieces definitely
check out the examples inside of know if
identity widget if you need reactor view
examples and essentially that's what I
wanted to show you I also wanted to talk
a little bit about metadata so you see a
little bit here that we're using the
metadata but I haven't really explained
it and I guess now it's a really good
time to explain it so there's two
different two types of metadata the ones
app metadata and one is user metadata
and that just refers to who can edit
that information so user metadata is
very powerful
I think it's underused and we should all
will use it more user metadata lets you
store essentially preferences for the
from the user and the user can edit it
and the add metadata the user cannot
edit it and it's only available to the
app developer to add things like roles
and provider source of information so
like if I logged in through github then
this provider would say get home so
that's that's just to show the type of
user and some metadata about the user
from the app point of view and then from
the user point of view they can set
their own information down in there so
there's another way to end to manually
do that which is head over to the
identity page and you can also set your
own user metadata down here and I can
just say like an admin role for example
potato
you can save that and when I reload
be seeing
it's a little login again I should be
seeing that my app metadata has new
roles for admin and potato and this you
can gate your functionality based on
this so the other the other thing is you
can actually use JavaScript and throw in
more fields on on here and so that would
involve that's not functionality that
know if I've done any widget offers you
and that leads us to a discussion of go
true j/s and friends so what Coach what
know if I did any widget is it's
actually a high level widget right that
comes with its own user interface and
it's actually an abstraction over a
smaller underlying service called go
true and here is the host here is the go
true link and this is the underlying
platform on which the user identity
service is being run so now if
identities code of the what the
marketing term for the product is but go
true is the underlying open source
project where you can run your own
authentication service so this is
written in go not very accessible to
JavaScript people so then we have a
library on top of that called go true
Jas and go to Jas is a very very small
library that basically reflects the
capabilities of the go true
functionality so it just kind of
it just kind of reflects the the api's
of of all this and so here is where you
want to update for example the user
attributes and add any metadata that you
may want to me you may want to use so go
to j/s is very low level and you may
want to write in something in between so
if you this this comes with no user
interface and has a lot of Doc's done
here and so choosing between something
with a user interface and a noise
interface at low level there may be some
in between that you may wish for so we
also have this something I maintain
react native identity which is the
reactive bindings for
don't UJS and that just provides go to J
as as a react hug as well as a context
that you that you put over your your app
so you just provide the context provide
the instance and you can use it as a
react hug so that's a very nice way to
use the go to GS and then if you want to
bring your identity widget with react
you can you can then use react Alif
identity widget I know there's so many
libraries but these are meant to help
rather than hurt I'm just trying to show
you how to choose between them so this
is the exact same it's a port of
nullified entity widget but because you
don't have to ship your own framework
it's a lot lighter so it's only solely
six kilobytes and it's got all the
functionality of reacting with identity
you can provide you can use your
identity as a hook and it has a nice
user interface that you don't have to
code up and obviously you could you can
bring your own styling if you want to
this is all optional for Gatsby users
there's also a plugin for Gatsby that
just basically helps you figure out the
details behind wrapping the identity
context provider for Gatsby
you don't really really need it but it's
just so nice to have okay so those are
the ecosystem of libraries all around
authentication just trying to make your
life a little easier but the two main
libraries to be aware of our go-to j/s
and nullified any widget and then the
react variants of that if you care to
use them they may save you some time
they certainly save me some time it's
been since I'm talking about the
integration between nullified entity and
nullify functions and it's very
integrated so that's the very very nice
piece what we'll do here is we'll look
at the functions that we have and we'll
create a function
we'll be useful for our demo purposes so
I'm using nullify dev and I'm and this
is my alias for Nell five functions
create and we're going to go for the
authenticated protected function
template and this is just a nice way too
so that I don't have to memorize how to
do this I can just fire it up and it
will just give me a basic template that
does that so you can see here that what
is essentially doing is that nullify
places the user if they're logged in on
the context and and then checks if the
context if the user exists if the user
does exist then you get a response with
offs true if the user does not exist
then the in a response if a 401 and a
console.log that's a little bit snarky
so the way to run this is to have in
local development know if I dev again I
have an alias and so that runs the
functions together with the front-end
and so now let's test this by using
nullify functions invoke so ntl
functions invoke and that will let us
choose the protected function trigger
and here we can finally understand what
it means to have emulated nullify
identity authentication headers so by
default we're actually passing yes so
I'm just gonna hit yes and it says data
off true which is that's what that's
what is reflected over here
so you can develop your functions as you
go along and this will this all live
reload and if you want to see what
happens when there's no identity
actually to skip all that functionality
you can actually just pass in the name
of the function so function so no
identity
and it says data not allowed and also
logs out no claims speak on so that's
great for developing and once your once
you're happy with your function you can
actually integrate that with your
front-end so here I still have my friend
and continuing step my friend going
let's actually see how to wire it up
with the protective function so over in
index J yes I have my click Handler over
here so let's make a little ping so like
a new click Handler and I'll click click
to equals 2
and that will get the card user as well
and here in the user object we have this
very interesting thing called the token
and we can use this access token to make
requests so let's make a little request
over here so fetch dots sets dotnet
Liffe I slash functions slash I what did
what did I call it protected
function and then we have to supply some
headers so headers authentication
there
user
dot
touken access token
then console.log
so actually I misspelled that I need to
make I need to make this authorization
and I need to dot Jason it Jason and
then I can console.log it
alright let's wire up the button click
for this to happen and now instead of
regular dev server I have to run the
nullified dev dev server so notice that
the service functions are being served
on port 3 4 5 6 7 and then the parcel
server is being served on port 1 2 3 4
and both of them are being joined on
localhost 8 8 8 8 so that's the one I
actually want and if I if I go to 1 2 3
4 that it's not going to have a working
function for me because there's no proxy
to redirect the functions so I'm on
localhost 82 8 right now and I have that
new button and it's called it something
better like off function so
and click it let's see the response that
I get back
all right so I click the all function it
sends off to my back-end which is
running it which decodes the JSON web
token that I attach from my bearer token
and and then I can you I can do that can
do stuff with that data inside of the
servers function and then respond back
with whatever I want
Here I am responding with off true but
you can respond with anything that you
want let me log out
let's see the equivalent response for
that all right and clearing all this as
well so now I'm not logged in and I'm
going to try and do all function ah says
cannot be properly took it of null of
none oh no that's very true so let me
just say something like user and and
so if I'm not logged in let's see what
will happen
so it says unauthorized over here so we
can have a catch for example and they
would say you should log it
you should login
in fact you can do something really cool
and have a little gate on this piece of
information over here so something like
X dot data equals not allowed
we can just prompt fair login if not we
can just console.log out the information
so now we're not logged in and if I try
to do this function which requires a
login it's gonna ping my back-end and be
denied and then come back and
immediately ask for a login so that's a
pretty cool integration of servlet
functionality and authentication
now that's not the only integration
there's some other integrations as well
if you check over for event triggered
functions there's three that we're going
to be talking about that are triggered
well based on events and we can look for
them in the function stocks and if you
scroll down to adventure good functions
you can see a whole list of them but I
just wanted to highlight the
identity-based ones because those are
extremely useful for doing anything when
people sign up or log in to your site so
we're gonna try and scaffold out an
identity function just to see how that
works together with your function and
nullified dev an identity workflow so
I'm using the five functions create and
we'll pick the identity signup template
and create a template like this and it
pretty much ships with a lot of decent
boilerplate already and one thing you'll
notice is that there it's call identity
signup and that's a hard-coded name
those these are all special names which
are recognized by nullify functions and
their get triggered when certain events
happen so on this one identity signup
well it happens when signup happens and
you can you can decode or D structure
from the body and look at the user
object and then assign different
parameters like metadata on the object
so as you're developing your event
triggered functions I highly recommend
testing it locally first before pushing
it to production because you might run
into bugs that you didn't cache and it's
better to catch bugs faster so that you
have a faster development cycle so the
best way to do that is in nullify a dev
so I'm gonna start out in that left hide
EV on one side and this will start up
the function server and on the other
side we're also going to start up a
function invocation so here we're gonna
parse sample data so we just need to
parse in one thing that makes this
different from normal nullify functions
testing is that it has extra information
on the user right like this user email
dot whatever
so now if I dev understands that and has
a special hard-coded behavior for these
functions so here we're going to say
we're going to try and invoke the net
Liffe identity sign up and instead of
the usual prompt we're gonna get just a
sample payload passed into the function
it's gonna run through that code it's
going to return with for example here we
we've passed in a user with trust this
company calm so it's gonna pass in this
is the return of after metadata of roles
of editor and with some extra
functionality as well as sign
dynamically inside of the service
function and you can also test this in
production by dropping out of nullify
dev and pushing it to production so and
so here it would be another if I deploy
prod my shortcut for that is n deploy so
I will just do that so now when you
click on the site and you look at the
deploy logs you should see that it's
uploading three functions and the third
function that is being deployed is the
identity signup function that's great so
let's have a look at what that looks
like
so we all head over to the production
site that we just deployed and we'll try
to have some sort of person sign in so
let's so let's try to sign up as someone
from trust this company actually let's
just sign up as his total stranger and
let's see what happens with that
stranger stranger at danger com stranger
we already turned off the confirmation
email so I can just put in a
non-existent email it's totally fine and
I'm logged in as a stranger that's
totally fine now and let's have a look
at what the metadata comes back as
so let's see the metadata over here so
we logged it out and here we have
strange danger comm and we have been
assigned the roles of visitor and that's
in alignment with what happened with our
identity signup function which validated
the user email and said oh this doesn't
come from my company it comes from a
stranger at danger com so I'm gonna give
this a roll of visitor so that's
something that only the app can do and
the user cannot do but the user can
supply extra metadata around that to
store some preferences or something and
this these are all things that they can
adjust and you can access on the user
metadata object so that's good let's
sign out and then sign in as someone
from the company so employee e 8 6 7 5 3
or 9 and so employee at trust this
company comm so I'm just following here
so this will pass the validation and we
expect it to get an editor axis so
employee whatever so I signed up I can
close this and now when you look at the
sign-in information I have I'm employee
just as company.com and that's
accordingly I've been given better
permissions as a editor rather than a
visitor and again I can do some dynamic
data as well and check my information as
a user so those are event triggered
functions you can use identity signup to
assign roles just like we showed you can
use that to to set up a new field in a
database you can use identity validate
to reject people from even signing out
because of some other blacklist or some
other rules that you may have and
there's identity login for doing things
when people log in one important caveat
that I want to share with people is that
identity signup only fires for email and
password sign ups right now and doesn't
eye fire for external providers so you'd
have to make a separate trigger for that
using nullify functions
but it's relatively straightforward to
set up we have an open issue for this on
go true and you're welcome to contribute
if you can but that says is that's what
stands right now as to the limitations
of the event triggered functions on
nullify ok so we already talked a little
bit about metadata management and and
how that works together with functions
so before we finish this section once
you may wish to also retrieve the form
data after sending it in so there's a
couple ways to do that one of the
clearest examples is this demo done by
full Hawksworth called gem stack
comments so the this is a demo for jam
stack comments with nullify forms and
functions and you can leave comments
here it would get posted to a review
queue and these are all then pulled from
the forms submission data back into the
site and generated from there so if
you're keen on that definitely have a
look at the source code it's gonna be
somewhere inside this gulp file and you
can just see that you put together some
of these environment variables which are
also documented inside of this project
hit the write API endpoint and then you
can do whatever you want with it so
that's the that's the rough idea behind
retrieving the form submission
programmatically obviously you can
download it via CSV or other manual
processes if you want and for further
documentation you should definitely have
a look at the open API of nullify and
that's down here and then you can scroll
down to the forum section where you can
find every single endpoint and what they
offer so these are these are very very
good sources of finding out and building
out your feature that you desire and
will have a piece at the end of this
series about the nullify API and how you
can build your own no effect clients
with this whole thing ok so on to the
last piece of this video which is the
paid features just to briefly mention
that
exist and what you can do with them so
the first is branded Roth
so branded Olaf is relevant to this part
of the identity settings where you can
see site visitors can see your own app
and doesn't it doesn't have to mention
that laughs I remember when we signed up
with github and Google to as external
providers we use the enough identity app
but we could actually use our own app
and do our own automation and settings
with that there's also SSO features this
is alongside the role-based access
control on the business plan and you can
also upgrade it individually on the
identity plan for just nullified entity
by itself the same goes for audit logs
for checking for understanding who's
signing who's signing in and out of your
site so for example when I go over to
the site that we've been working with I
have all these people logging in and out
I can just head to the identity audit
log and see all the sign in and out
actions over here to see if there's
something fishy going on and lastly
we're going to customize the custom
sender as well so a custom outgoing
email address so it doesn't come from
nullify com when people want the email
confirmation so that's probably not
everything but those are the main
features I figured I should highlight
that if you need to for a production
application you can definitely pay for
it but everything else that we do
presented is completely free so that's
pretty nice and that's nullify identity
you
the best way for me to explain nullify
CMS is to show it to you in action
nullify CMS is an open source project
that is worked on by employees in lfi
but is completely separate as far as
technology is concerned from natla phi
except for one connection point which is
the gate gateway you can use nullify CMS
without nullify and there's some
documentation on that we're just going
to show why you might pick it over some
of the other headless CMS options and
the key is to understand that it's a git
based CMS so there's no extra server to
pay for or maintain it's all within your
get together with your source code
there's an explanatory video here with
more details but we're going to be going
over much of that in our course today
and so let's actually see this in action
notify users notify CMS of course
especially for the blog for example so
here these are blog posts that are
drafted and published and previewed and
edited all in nullify CMS and that's
that's a very wonderful thing so let's
take a look at how this works internally
in the URL there's a special endpoint
that we've set up called slash admin
endpoint and that gets us to the nutloaf
ICMS admin panel and notify CMS with the
good gateway uses nullified entity to
login we'll explain all this integration
but fortunately you already know what
notify identity is and this is a very
familiar which--it to you by now I'm
gonna sign in with my employee email and
my password and that's and now we can
see the M in backend of nullify so we
have a few collections named here and
some on some blog posts and also you're
able to see them so to spread out or are
in layers we haven't really set it up we
just put titles on just cuz that's all
we need you can also see workflow and
media and we'll talk about those two in
turn but let's go ahead and start a new
blog
and I'm just gonna cancel and so you can
see here two things there are there's a
left hand side which with a bunch of
form fields and on the right hand side
I'll previewed and so this is very cool
it's it's actually a full react app that
looks exactly like a blog so let's have
a sample post test post please ignore
lower rim it's um
I have my author picture be registered
so it my author picture signs up it
shows up as well and note if I change
the date it shows up on both sides can
select a pre generator topic you can add
turns I can type in some text but then I
can also write in markdown which is very
nice for code
I can even configure custom fields like
for example the street field which will
show what the tweet
looks like
described in some metadata
there's a special field in this editor
interface where you can actually add
images as well which is not usual for it
for markdown editors but you can do that
right here and you can choose a new pay
new image to upload for example I can
upload a recent image of mine and I can
select it to be included and that will
show up in my preview which is very nice
me and I can collapse this and keep
editing my content down below so all
this is very nice and this is especially
if you're working with a non-technical
audience but then also just for yourself
if you write a lot and you would just
want a nicer editing experience you can
notice the scroll sink as I go up and
down it's just very very cool and so
yeah once I'm happy I can save and when
Elif SEMS that does a couple things
actually kicks off a PR that sends to
the github repo of nanofied calm and
then it immediately has the status over
here to check for a preview so right now
this is in a draft mode because I just
saved I haven't published and I can set
the draft status to in review already as
well and no we'll talk about the editor
workflow but first let's talk about this
check for preview tag so what this does
in the backend let's have a look at the
source code for the dub dub dub so you
can see that Nell if I bought has
already created in lfi CMS page it's and
it's adding that file that I did it
marked down the image that I had already
was uploaded and you can see the deploy
preview down here working on the build
so this is why there's a check for
preview button because you can click
this if you want and continually check
for preview there's no preview yet so
this is still showing check for preview
but this is for basically there's
basically eliminating any differences
between the
wysiwyg preview and the final article
and we'll talk a little bit about how we
can set up the correspondence between
the impanel sort of live preview as well
as the deploy preview which is almost
basically the real thing like you know
that based on continuous deployment once
you merge this PR in it will look
exactly like it does in a preview once
that deploy is live you can actually see
that status update in the PR and
obviously collaborate with your
co-workers insider PR but also inside
the CMS you can actually hit check for
preview again and it will turn into a
view preview button and when you view
the preview this will be a deploy
preview with your post exactly as it
will be inside of your actual content
and you can see the entire site index
together with that
very nice so let's talk a little bit
about editor workflow I'm gonna hit back
and check out the workflow section so
the post that I've made is now in the
draft section together with some of the
content that I have I can delete I can
publish I can drag it through if for
example I have a reviewer that I'm
working with or I'm just sort of working
this in progress whereas this is just
more of a nice box and once it's ready
to publish I can just take this over to
the ready section and either
automatically publish it or manually hit
the publish button whenever I'm ready to
launch my new blog post over in the
media section we can check on the images
that I've uploaded nothing much else
here but now let's talk a little bit
about how its configured how come we can
upload both images as well as markdown
and that's actually all in the
configuration that's contained within
the repo itself so here I've been the
back end of the blog page and nullify
CMS has a special config file called
config dot llamo and here you basically
spec out all the details that know if I
see miss needs to know about your site
so we'll talk about collections later
but these is that's basically the schema
of all the content that you enter in but
basically you I you specify your
back-end your site URL your publish mode
which we opted into the editorial
workflow for a more fine-grained process
as well as a specifying a media folder
which is where we want the github bot to
store our uploaded images and the public
folder which is where we're going to
serve our images from so a lot of times
this is a nested folder so we just want
to tell notify CMS where to actually
expect it so that's the difference
between the media and the public folder
let's talk a little bit about what this
this word back-end means it's like
that's a verboten word in nullify but
really we're just using one of many
configurations for
or integration with get providers so
obviously the the one that we lead with
is get gateway which integrates with
nullified entity we'll talk about this
and this is and this has to be measured
in contrast with the others which is
integrations with github get lab and
bitbucket so let's have a look at these
back let's have a look at these backends
they what's common among github get lab
and bitbucket is that all your CMS users
need to be directly need to have commit
access through the authentication
services of each of these services so
get lab you need to login with your get
lab account bitbucket same thing and get
help the same thing and then they can
commit obviously you may not want to
give everyone commit rights to your code
you may just want them to be able to
send in content and let the bots take
care of it and that's what get gateway
does for you
together with nullify identity and
that's the tight integration there
fortunately you know everything about
know if identity already so what I'm
gonna show you is just a documentation
forget gateway which is over here and it
explains how you can set it up if you
don't want to use nullify because this
is an open source project and you can
see all the source code over here in the
get gateway repo so to be clear you
don't need notify identity to work to
use notify CMS it's just a nice to have
because you want your popular publishers
and your authors and your editors to be
able to review content without being
able to commit to code and in all these
other options you have to give them
commit rights because that's how it
would work okay so that's it for our
intro to nullify CMS but we're gonna get
our hands dirty a little bit and
actually set a new thing up from a
template so that's the best way to start
with it and I don't know if I've been
clear enough at the beginning but he'll
if ICMS does not depend on reacted users
react for the editor but it's amazingly
tech agnostic like it works of Hugo it
was Jekyll or middleman Gatsby
and that's pretty pretty freakin amazing
given that it's also showing you a live
preview but it is true that the largest
number users come from the Gatsby and
react ecosystem so we're gonna have a
look at how to set that up so one thing
we're going to start from is a template
and that's the template that's
maintained by the the notify CMS team I
do want to pay some special attention to
the URL of this template of this deploy
to nullify button so if you watch my
earlier videos you should be aware of
what the deploy to notify button does
but basically it helps you set up a fork
here we're actually doing something new
which is appending this at stack equals
CMS flag and that just basically helps
to set up a get gateway Plus nullify
identity setup just from a single deploy
to nullify button click which is the
standard one that you see with any
nullify the open-source site
okay so let's deploy from a template so
I'm going to click here and it's gonna
set up that one click deploy that we all
know and love
so I signed in and now it's creating a
repo name I'm just gonna leave it
unchanged
I actually already have the same name
here so I'm just gonna add it to to it
but notice that it's actually showing
that it's gonna set up gate gateway and
identity as well just because we added
that little tag at the end of at stack
equals CMS if you didn't have this you
could set it up yourself just by
clicking a few buttons but this just
makes it a one click deploy type of
situation so that's always very handy to
have especially when getting started
with something okay so we have a new
site and just for good measure we can
see that identity is already set up for
me as well as in the settings I can see
that gate gateway is already set up as
well okay and that would be in settings
identity all the way down here with the
gate gateway services and you can set
this up yourself a few if you chose so
choose there's actually take a quick
look at what this one clean deploy gets
us so let's head over here so we get a
nice landing page we start with some
content down here that hopefully we can
customize so some stories from a blog
and you can read more on the slash blog
and obviously here we see that lazy
loading fanciness from gatsby but
otherwise it is pretty straightforward
blog now you can see
there's also a products page that you
can edit and a contact page with nullify
forums and other forum examples down
below
let's take a look at what that looks
like from the source code perspective
so when I clicked that deploy to nullify
button I also clone that source code and
again in the NLF ICMS world you should
always start with the config dot yeah
mol file so let's have a look at the
static folder admin route config yeah mo
it's pretty much always in something
around like that where the final route
will be fubar nullified comm slash admin
right and then it would just look for a
conflict mo up in there we got the back
end config file and again just to just
to note that all this is actually in the
docs we're not really covering anything
you know new here I'm just explaining it
as I go along in words that I could
understand so here we're setting the
back end with the Gateway there's other
back-end options that we already talked
about and then we have a media and
public folder again already explained
that this is where you want to store it
inside of git and this is where it's
going to live in the public URL and now
we come to these concepts of collections
and so we want to talk about collections
folder collection sources file
collections folder is actually the
easier one and folder you can think
about as just templates for your blog
right so when I edit my my blog I want
to be able to specify a date have that
be broken out to your month day and slug
and the slug will be created for me the
template key can be given to me as well
and I can have some other fields like
description feature post and you can
notice that I'm using all these widgets
which are text boolean image markdown
this state time and these are all
default widgets that come with nullify
CMS so let's have a look at the widgets
and these are all the common widgets you
can see the options available to you and
some notes on how they behave and let's
have a look at them in action because I
feel like we're still too abstract in
terms of what we're doing over here
so let's fire up the page and let's go
to admin now I haven't set this up for
invites so here it's only login so I
need to let it be able to sign up
obviously you want to be very careful
with this because once people sign up
they can also contribute content and you
don't want just anyone to sign up so
let's change our registration
preferences to open and I'll just go
ahead and add like a github external
provider as well and as you know the
nullified entity widget will pick that
up so now I can sign up and I or I can
just also continue a github and I'm just
gonna make a new blog post and just walk
through that process again but this time
we're going to have the schema open in
front of us and compare them from side
by side so here we'll see that we have a
title the template key is hidden and
this is this determines the layout and
in gatsby's perspective well look at the
title and we'll try and say Lauren if
some will have a publish date with the
date/time widget there used to be a date
wage it but now that's deprecated so you
always used to date time widget that
doesn't seem to display in our template
over here and we can go fix that if we
want to the description I can just say
foo bar Baz whatever featured posts yeah
make a feature post why not I've taken
image I can reuse the selected image or
I'll just make my own because Hawaii not
okay tuck that in there upload
choose selected and I'll type in some
text I'll just grab some of this stuff
hook it in there maybe I'll make this a
markdown thing okay cool and that looks
like some content and tech JavaScript
whatever
publish it notice that I don't have
editorial workflow set up so I'm when I
publish it immediately creates that PR
that's currently rebuilding so give me a
sec let's head to the deploys
you
so you saw me cancel that deployer over
there because I just I'm just importing
I'm just uploading the image I actually
need to build the blog one thing that we
can look at while this is building its
also look at the PR that's happening in
our project so over here there's no PR
because we haven't set up editorial
workflow but the coda is actually
committed it directly for me including
that date time that I talked about as
well as the description featured posts
all those fields that we specified in
our config okay so the new site is live
and we'll go over and refresh and we
should be able to see the new blog post
and there's no date in the preview and
that's as planned so the other type of
collection so that's the folder
collection that we talked about over
here
and that's basically sending all these
templates to go into each of these blog
post folders that have been declared and
that's that's a pretty clear and
intuitive way to use a CMS the other way
to use this know if a CMS is is as a
file collection and here we call our
file collection pages and we've got a
bunch of different pages we've got the
landing page we've got the about page
for the products page and the idea here
is that these there will not be repeated
copies of these these are just
individual files and we're using the CMS
as a way to edit the content of these
files dynamically and none of ICMS will
be smart enough to handle that so let's
have a look at how that works on the
inside again we're going to go into the
content manager and so the blog as we
maintain over here has the is the folder
collection and the file collection is
all these pages actually switch renamed
over here we head to the pages and we
can edit any one of these things so I
just edit the landing page the landing
page has these widgets set up on the
left
and this preview on the right which as
you already saw is pretty much the exact
same as what is in production so we can
just say no 5 CMS is really great
CMS seeing without a CMS server
and we can blah blah blah look at all of
this awesomeness of widgets and editing
and and wizzy witness it this is really
really hard to do I wanna see don't know
how they do this but I'm glad that they
do
so let's save this again it's directly
hitting to publish we can obviously set
up the editorial workflow by configuring
that inside of the field over here just
a day
editorial workflow field and now when I
look at the commits again I should be
able to see the latest commits that
we're updating the pages of the title
and subheading and that does again hooks
right back in to nullify and kicks off a
new build okay so that's about it the
last piece that we didn't cover is the
filter field that's going to be very
handy for basically filtering out by
language so for example I want to edit
in English or Spanish and have different
layouts and widgets for those things
those are very very helpful as well and
probably the most common question for
most blogging situations is needing to
schedule posts because there's no
running server you need a way to make
blog post go live at a point in time so
the natural solution is to set your blog
post date at some point in the future
and then when and then you and then you
set up your builds to run every day
every minute every hour or whatever it
is and once that time has passed for the
blog post to be published then that
build will pick it up so essentially all
you need to do is set up a cron job
uh-huh and zapier is a really good way
to do it
so the zapier integration of a nullify
lets you just use this app and you can
start a deploy of notify sites on a
daily schedule which is pretty cool
there are other methods to do it this
article from Flavio copes essentially
tells you about the zapier integration
with a little bit more documentation and
screenshots which I highly recommend and
those for those who want to try out
something more service without the zet
without paying for zapier you can try to
set up your own with servlets framework
and literally setting a scheduling a
publish is as simple as leaving a
comment inside of github
so that's a those are very interesting
ways to schedule posts but essentially
if you were paying attention during the
notify build section where we talked
about build hooks then you can
essentially fire off from any old device
you can have a Raspberry Pi that sends a
ping to your build server all of that
good stuff the last section of what
we're gonna cover today is has to do
with media so so far we've been
uploading media directly target folder
that obviously has scalability issues
for large images and large numbers of
images and so you may want to explore
one of the media partners that we have
so the probably the best-known is
culinary cloud Neri essentially lets you
sign up for free and then they'll manage
your images for you all you need to do
is add a media library key to your
config llamó and since and give them
your ordinary cloud name as well as your
API key and that's about it
now if I will upload there instead of
your github similar principle for upload
care upload care is another service that
just focuses on assets storing and not
just images but just in everything in
general and a similar place and the
thing you just sign up for them and then
give you a public key and lastly we'll
talk about an elephant large media which
actually is a git LFS implementation so
you don't store your images inside of
get you actually store it somewhere else
in an elephant large media server and
then that will firewall proxy and give
you the right sizes of your images audio
video for you without building a
repository so we'll actually talk about
that in the next section on nullify
add-ons for everything else but apart
from that you should be all set to go to
do to setup your site with nullify CMS
okay now we're onto the net loaf I
add-ons section this is going to be a
relatively quick section because a lot
of these are just Show and Tell demos
and also it's a very growing field it's
probably the absolute newest out of all
of these different sections with that
we've covered so far and let's just get
right into it so the first one is
nullify analytics this was just launched
in June of 2019 and it's server-side
analytics and you can check out the
product page over here and get a gist of
what it's talking about but the main
idea is that because the service side
it's unblockable because we're literally
you have to serve the files for people
to access your site and if they access
your site and if we serve the file to
them then they're definitely a visitor
and that's important because a lot of us
use ad blockers like privacy badger and
you block origin to block our ads so
here's a way to get past that and get
real numbers but then also avoid
tracking personal information because
notify analytics simply doesn't accept
personal information so you can't track
it so the best way to get started is
just to go to any site that you have and
just hit to the analytics section on the
top and you can read through this and
and click to enable analytics for $9 a
month you can fill that out but I
already have that filled in my other
site so I'm gonna go to there it is per
site as for right now obviously work
with the salespeople if you need better
pricing than that and you can also read
the documentation for for more
information about what each of these
numbers mean that's gonna be extremely
important so here's my own personal site
I can see total page views for the past
30 days unique visitors and total
bandwidth use unique visitors is an
important question and I'll come to that
so these are daily numbers and these are
monthly numbers daily numbers are I had
a spike on September 14 when had a big
blog post go up unique unique visitors
how do you tell unique visitors if we
don't track them and this is straight up
just unique IPs and then certain pros
and cons to that with regards to double
for example if you're on a mobile phone
versus on your desktop and you're on
different networks you have different
IPS and you be kind of twice but then
also you'll be undercounting people who
share IP so for example in a co-working
space or a library or airport or
something so it is by IPS as long as
you're comfortable with that and you're
and you can see the spikes here and
there you should be relatively
comfortable with what the what the
traffic numbers say about what's going
on with your site
additionally something else that you
can't see here is is that when you
actually turn it on I know if I was able
to backfill in time for the past 30 days
because and that's just because now if I
already has the server allows it just
hasn't set up the scripting for your
site to spit out the analytics for you
so that has extra running cost and
that's what you're paying for it to
backfill you know you don't have to
enable it and then track the limitation
of course is that right now it only
offers you 30 days but that is
definitely something that the team is
clean keen on working on for offering
you more than 30 days and rolling
windows of stuff so you might notice
that unique visitors on a daily basis
and a unique on a monthly basis kind of
doesn't add up if you try to add every
single day up and that's intentional
because these are unique above over a
month whereas these are unique within a
day so that's all explained in the
documentation and you can definitely
look at the specific definitions of what
each of these numbers mean and there you
go that's that's what they offer they
offer you they can tell you what the top
pages are a lot of them will be sort of
service workers type stuff but then also
you can also look at things that are
missing so for example if I forgot a
mobile icon that's a very good sign that
I should probably put it there because
people are checking stuff out of mobile
they're checking out for my RSS stay
that that's or they trying to hack me I
can also see what's going on over there
there a lot of sub pages we'll get a lot
of spots sniffing for the WP admin login
page and that's just something that we
you know being Jam stack just cards
against for you and that's very nice you
may also feel you may also want to
filter out some of these commonly
requested things which are not which are
not relevant to your site and that those
are function that's functionality that
is being worked on by the team as well
as you may want to offer a client-side
navigation because this these are only
server-side these this is where people
land but then subsequent navigations for
people using front-end frameworks aren't
being tracked and again that's another
common feature request that hasn't been
implemented yet still this is a new
feature and it's it's done very very
well so the team is very keen on working
on it
okay so now we're gonna move on to the
next add-on which is has a little bit
more of a learning curve than clicking a
button which is a large media and to
explain large media I should have to
explain what gived LFS is get LFS is a
way to large store large files together
with versioning in git so everything
that we love about git except that with
get one of the problems is when you
store large files in it and everyone has
to download it and it persists forever
in history and that's not very good
especially if you don't use it or access
it very much like you just want to
access it for content so that's why you
use git LFS and that's a that's a spec
that you can just clone and install and
use without nullify what nullified does
for you is provide a place to store it
so that's where know if a large media
comes in you can see the product page
over here and learn a little bit about
how to deal with the problem no if I
also know if a large media also comes of
any constants or image transformations
and we'll talk a little bit about what
that means but let's actually check out
how to how to implement it the best way
to learn where to implement it is on the
docks the large media page has some
information about it here as well as
some prerequisites and it really is
dependent on your CLI so we have already
introduced the CLI in various sections
of previous videos but this one is
important it's a plugin that you just
install with the CLI so now every time
you add
a large media file you just have to say
get LFS track and the path to that media
file and you can use wildcards as well
for entire folders and nullify will just
upload that to theirs to nullify servers
when you commit so your workflow is
exactly like push and pull with and all
that and let's have a look at what that
looks like on our demo so I'll demo over
here has a bunch of images with high
definition and you can see the github
repo over here and we can see how this
is all set up with git LFS in the master
branch this is the one without get LFS
so if you go into the static folders and
look for the images and look at each of
these images they're just going to be
the large images that that we see over
here and here's some apples and that's
not very efficient obviously that's not
very scalable this is fine for these
small examples so it's gonna be out of
control pretty soon especially with
images of a few megabytes or even
gigabytes and you can think about videos
and audio assets as well over here so
what happens with this folder and get
LFS is when I switch over and I head to
images and I look at one of these
I don't see I see that the file size is
286 kilobytes but I see that it's been
replaced by just a pointer and now the
pointer is just pointing to the git LFS
server which in this case is nullify
large media you can see the
corresponding files tracked on the large
media section of your site so head over
to the large media section and then you
can see that all the files that are
being tracked as well as filter out for
one of them if you have a lot of files
and that's very very handy and then the
other capability of notify large media
is and this is a special case for images
is that you can resize them so there's
no point serving high resolution images
every time or manually resizing them by
yourself you could just use an API for
that and so nullify provides that API
and it's called image transformation
let's have a look at what that looks
like over here so I'm going to apply the
parameters to this and it's reduced it
to a width of 100 and a height of 100
but this is a rectangular image so it's
just gonna fit to that I can also use
the smart crop parameter and that's
actually going to be a hundred by a
hundred and it uses the smart crop
parameter we can also make this let's
say 500 on the width and that just gives
you exactly what you want so that's a
very great way to just send over the
wire exactly the subset of the image
that you need and you can change the
parameters whether you need to preserve
the aspect ratio or you need to just fit
exact dimensions if you need to you can
see more details about image
transformation over on the documentation
page and especially on how to supply the
query parameters to get the examples
that you need but it's gonna be pretty
straightforward once you understand what
it does so that's nullify large media
relatively straightforward large file
hosting and image transformation product
alright that is that for image
transformation and large media and now
we're on to even more exciting ground
which is the add-on marketplace
and this is a relatively new part of
nullify as well winters which is working
with third-party add-on providers and
it's not something we really shout about
because there's just not a lot of them
and it's quite a new initiative but it's
definitely a growing area of focus for
nullify and if you're interested in
working on an add-on for your company
together with nullify definitely get in
touch but we're just gonna focus on two
existing add-ons that you can use today
the first is gonna be fauna DB a lot of
people when they move up in terms of use
cases from marketing pages to submitting
forms to authentication and CMS and then
they at some point they become an app
and need some sort of persistence from a
database and you can use firebase and
other databases like MongoDB Atlas
through nullify functions and now if I
dev and all that good stuff but it's
easier to onboard with an add-on that
manages a lot of the backend syncing of
environment variables and setting up of
instances and all that so it's all
integrated in your net effective
workflow so here we'll talk a little bit
about for a minute on a DB so the Fonda
DB I think the best place to find out
about it actually is not on that laughs
I the best place to find out about it is
on a podcast one of my favorites is
software engineering daily and Evan
Weaver the CEO of fauna talked about why
he started fauna and basically he was
one of the early early early database
engineers at Twitter and he faced
scalability problems because they were
using no sequel databases well they had
to migrate to no sequel because they
faced scalability problems and so that's
what fauna is a globally distributed as
a compliant database and it has a lot of
really nice features including their own
query language which is very powerful
for some use cases like field level
authorization and graph qaul first
support so the best way to start
thinking about how to use fauna together
with nullify functions is to look at
some of the announcement posts
the font of Adam was definitely in the
prototyping phase for a few months and
so July there was this example from
David Wells talking a little bit about
how to set it up from a create react tap
point review and setting up a full
service database II full-stack fauna DP
enabled nullify function and that's the
demo that you can view on the nullifier
repo because it's the one done by
nullify people and you can definitely
think about the structure that you might
want for a back-end for your credits and
more recently into in September of 2019
we actually announced the full general
availability of the add-on together with
an authentication and claims process so
and so so now it's fully supported foot
so now it's fully officially supported
by nullifying fauna and the way that you
add it you can definitely create it
through the network I CLI and these are
the commands at ons create fauna and
then you can claim that instance with
add-ons off and the fondant team
themselves have also worked on a demo
for you that can show off what you can
do with it and the idea of this demo is
to show you how to integrate and nullify
identity nullify and fauna all in one
full stack app and obviously it's a
to-do app because that's the hello world
of everything and we can log in for
example with our nail if I identity
process that we know and love and once
we're logged in you can see that we are
able to create lists to do MVC and I can
access that list and add a list
and do everything that you normally do
with crud
and you can still go back out this list
would be guaranteed not to be accessible
to other users because of how fana does
field level authentication so definitely
check out how fana works you can also
look at their Docs for for the fana
add-on specifically or just getting
started with fauna in general and and
it's a very powerful database for with
great developer experience for service
jam stack users the next add-on we're
gonna look into is the very good
security or vgs add-on and vgs is a
company it's not just something that you
should have if you treaty has a company
that solves a very real problem of a
very different nature which is
collecting your users data in a pci and
HIPAA compliant way so there is some
more information on the docs but i'm
just gonna go through a rough intro of
what you shouldn't know in case you
might need this and so the idea is that
when you're using something like nullify
forms you might become you might be
collecting some information so let's
look at this demo on the vgs github page
and it's also linked in the show notes
and over here we can see that we're
taking a form we've got some name
information all this stuff and we don't
want this to be submitted to us via
nullify functions or nullify forms we
just want to send it on to do for
example a processing check like a
background api check and maybe take
payment through stripe or something
so what vgs does is an intermediary that
steps in and wipes and replaces all of
these all these fields with unique IDs
those functions can then remotely check
fiji as for those date that those values
none of it hits nullify or nullifies
logging so here we've processed a stripe
transaction even though we haven't saved
the users data from credit card or other
information so that's the rough idea of
why you might need it definitely go
check out their introductory video just
to explain a little bit more about what
vgs
does they're very good at what they do
and they have more docs for you on the
announcement blog post as well as on the
vgs doc site itself so definitely go
check that out
okay and just to wrap up the video we
are going to talk a little bit about the
premium add-ons and these are things
that you might want to look into if your
company relies on that lafha especially
for enterprises and large teams and you
might need some of these premium support
and performance add-ons and so the best
way to find out information for that is
to go to the pricing page and just to
get an idea of like the security
features the performance features the
different CBN's that the free tier has a
CDN that everyone uses and then the
enterprise tier has bet dedicated CBN's
with more points of presence and better
performance as well as of time SLA s and
you can also specifically add support
add-ons
so there's dedicated response times and
champ and support channels as well as
high performance application delivery
network features that you might mean for
your high performance needs so all of
this is available on the pricing page
and you can contact sales for more
information about that I personally
don't know too much but it's good enough
to know that it exists if your app or
site needs it and that's it we're gonna
we've wrapped up our tour of nullify
add-ons to be clear everything else that
we've discussed so far are also add-ons
it's just that there's more to do with
each of them so I broke them out into
different videos but edge build and dev
are core parts of the platform and then
each of these are add-ons most of them
with free tiers that you can use and add
functionality to your app but none of
them are strictly required to use
nullify and you can definitely bring
other features as well a lot of them are
good partners of nullify and sponsors of
gem sack events
one benefit of being Jam stack is that
you're basically the first consumer of
your own set of API s and once you have
one consumer you can pretty easily
spread it to more so if you have a web
app you can spread to a mobile app to a
desktop app to a CLI and so on and so on
and so on
and nullify is no exception nullify
itself is Jam stack and nullified com is
hosted on nullified com so in this
section we're gonna be taking a look at
how to make your own net lafay client
and the best way to learn that is to
look at the documentation and also to
look at other clients that have already
been implemented and then you can
implement a notify client for whatever
purposes that you need if something that
we do is not working for you you can
make your own so the first place to see
this in action is after nullify com this
is always sort of the first-class
consumer of nullifiers api's and one way
to tell is to go to the page and hit the
network tab and just check out all the
API responses that have been called you
can filter for xhr over here
and you can see that we're hitting for
example like a sites endpoint with some
parameters and then that gets back the
responses that are then displayed here
as well as notifications then when you
enter a site you get some notifications
it deploys as well so you get deploys
this is the options ping let's look at
the get result and yeah you can see all
the deploy preview stuff that's
happening over here and so on and so
forth there's a lot that's happening and
they're all done through an API and
therefore pretty transparent to anyone
who wants to use them for other purposes
you should note that there are
authentication head tokens that you name
I won't afford and this would be located
in your nullify identity JW TS now that
you know that the API exists probably
the best way to learn more about it is
to check out the documentation these are
this is available on the official Docs
itself and you can check out links for
go in JavaScript API clients and it's
got some information about rate limiting
pagination and in particular if you want
to write your own deploy methods you
should read some of these information to
help you figure out how to deploy large
zip files and folders or files form
submissions that you programmatically
retrieve form information so you can
retrieve that within a function for
example and then reference it in your
page itself so it's not a write only
form and there are other ways to trigger
web hooks and and retrieve files
themselves without actually serving the
e without actually serving in that URL
the official API itself follows the open
API spec and therefore has a
programmatically generated documentation
page as a standalone and you can
naturally access this information in a
structured manner together with some
sample response shapes so you can
actually code faster for whatever use
cases that you're thinking of another
good client to look at is the CLI
Fornell
Ornella fight dev so this is the CLI
that you've been using it's completely
open-source which also means that you
can also check out how to do certain
things within the CLI and use them in
your own Nell effect client the
indentify CLI is built on top of the o
cliff framework from Salesforce and
Heroku therefore there's a bunch of
commands they're all located between
here and each of these are the commands
that you run including certain flags for
example whenever five functions create
that would invoke some flags over here
but you can also look at for example the
source code for a nullify deploy and
that's just a single file and you can
see how the CLI uses the this not
nullify and they start authenticate
instances to do things like getting
sites and deploying and and deploying
the sites and displaying the status of
them so all this wiring up between the
CLI and the meta file API happens
off-screen and it may be a little hard
to find so I'm just gonna do you the
favor of putting you directly and they
let enough I CLI utils so this is a
separate package because it's used in
multiple places in the CLI utils that
basically links up the GS clients which
is the JavaScript layer over the goal
client for Anila Phi and it wraps it
inside of a Oh cliff base command and
all this is probably foreign to you
right now but it will be helpful if you
need to dive into the code but basically
we export a base command here and we add
on all the methods like the
authentication method that you saw us
use earlier
we attach the nullify instance by inish
by initializing and then attaching it on
to that commands instance so this
library is useful for reusing the same
login credentials on the machine for
multiple clients so if you're logged in
on the CLI as well as desktop and so on
and you're not asked to login multiple
times but if you want to go down to the
lowest level of JavaScript dependency
definitely check out bjs client library
and this is the lowest level library
that lets you do everything imperative
lis but doesn't take care of access
token usage for you some nice community
clients that you can definitely check
out as well there's a menu bar app from
Stephan Judas this is the one I
personally use so if you click over here
you can actually see the reported
incidents that have been happening
recently you can check out the different
sites that you're managing and be
notified of the deploys you can toggle
to different deploys or trigger a new
deploy you can set different settings
for the for the app and all in all very
nice utility to have to give you
notifications of when apps are deploying
and updating so that's a brief tour of
the notify API you're definitely welcome
to use it and get in touch with us if
you need some help on something that
doesn't make sense and we are interested
in working with people to build more
stuff like all of this is open source
for a reason and we're happy to work
with people to do more things with
nullify for example a lot of people
install the notify CLI as part of their
continuous deployment process like they
have their own continuous deployment
tool chain and pipeline and then they
use notify CLI to just deploy the final
build assets but they don't really need
it if they understood the lower-level
tools or they could just build their own
tools to do other things that they wish
they could do so now if I API is the
ultimate low level flexible interface if
the interfaces that we have is
preventing you from building and doing
the stuff that you want to do
we made it we're here this is the final
part of the nullify series where we just
link you to more stuff that you can
learn the first part I should totally
tell you about is how to figure out if
something with its wrong with metla fire
itself that is the net afire status
there is a net 5 status comm page that
is updated whenever there is a confirmed
or reported incident and you can check
out the incident history if you think
you've been affected in one of your
sites as well as subscribe to updates
there's also a Twitter account that you
can follow to get more updates or just
check if your in Twitter and you can get
a link to what's going on over there if
you're not checking the status of notify
you want probably trying to debug
something that's in your build
unfortunately a lot of build issues are
user issues so there's not a lot that we
can do but we can at least document some
of the common gotchas so this is
actually in our Doc's that we document
them so this is actually in our Doc's
and these are common issues that people
face so we hope that some of this might
help in terms of something that you're
facing in particular my top tip is to
make sure that you can run your build
locally and it outputs what do you
expect before you deploy it and
introduce continuous deployment to your
build process for even more self-service
help you can head to the nullifier
community site where there are people
helping each other on nullify issues as
well as related static site generator
issues and for the FAQ you can check out
the common issue tag that has been
created by the support team and these
are capable typical issues that they've
run into supporting hundreds of
thousands of developers over the past 5
years if you're on the page here you can
have nullify support and depending on
the tier you can have support via email
or slack
or carrier pigeon it really depends on
your pricing plan with nullify and
lastly if you need to check something
with nullify you can also check them on
Twitter including hiring for including
getting a job with nullify support now I
don't know about you but I actually
learned a lot from watching talks so
these are some talks I picked out to
recommend to people for learning what
nullified does and is and Jam stack is
about Matt Billman gave this awesome
talk at Smashing San Francisco in 2016
basically giving the founding thesis on
nullify and it's it's all about what a
job SEC does and why there is a
resurgence in static site generators
Chris coiour talked recently about how
the front-end developers are now full
stack developers because of everything
that they've been enabled to do with the
jam stack Sara Dresner talked about how
the jam stack is a new way of joining
together API is JavaScript and markup
just like the iPhone that's not
inventing anything new but it's putting
to putting them together in a useful new
way and you can do it you can even do
things like e-commerce with the Josh
stack and it's actually better because
it's faster Phil Hawksworth
gives a really good talk on the agency
perspective because of his many years of
experience in agency life and how it can
lead to faster delivery times from a
waterfall cycle to a more continuous
approach the citrix team gave an
incredible talk recently about migrating
to jams that can nullify with their
Doc's team and how their business
processes and cost savings were very
very significant here for a large
enterprise use case Quincey Larson and
freako Kemp aren't an enterprise but
they do have massive scale on on the
order of millions of users and the in
Quincy also talked about how he serves
millions of users using the gem stack
because his number one priority is cost
and scale and that's if that's a perfect
fit for something like a gem stack
and lastly Jomon Ferguson of PayPal move
PayPal me to jam stack and we soon you
gave a talk about it and so this is e an
enterprise-level talk does not use
nullify but still talks about the
benefits and some problems with moving
to the chat stack that he solved so
these are all very good perspectives of
real-life use cases I also learned a lot
from how venture capitalists think about
think about things so the four places
that I recommend people go to are the
Andreessen Horowitz and kleiner perkins
investment pcs and nullify as well as in
kleiner perkins investment thesis red
point and CRV are also interested in
investing in the gem stack ecosystem so
if you're interested in starting a gem
stack startup you can check out their
roadmaps and ecosystems and think about
what parts of the ecosystem are lacking
crv also has another jasec ecosystem
chart and I strongly recommend checking
that out as well and thinking about
where you fit and what you want to use
and what you want to outsource so that's
the broad landscape of Jam sack there a
couple more resources that I want to
point you to to learn more first is Jeff
stat conf calm this is the premier Jeff
Zack conference organized by an elephant
but definitely not exclusive to nullify
there's Jam stack org with even more
resources about definitions marketing
material best practices examples
resources and stuff there is there's a
Jam static slack that you can join at
Jeff's I about slack calm there's a
older broader community called the new
dynamic and this is also a very active
slack Channel heavy bit one of the
investors in gem stack also puts out a
gem stack radio podcast with a bunch of
interviews that are really great just in
just covering the jams tech ecosystem as
well as developer experience and finally
nullify recently published a book with
O'Reilly on the modern web development
with the gem stack and this is a free
book you just have to give your email
and it is a pretty good read on why the
Jeff stack what is the job
second what and what you can do with it
so that's the summary of everything that
I know about nullify hopefully this
whole video series has been hopeful and
it's definitely the first iteration so
I'm keen on getting more feedback about
it and thank you for your time